that sound like mario
Hello!
Hi!
Oh hi boomie.
Give you a kiss.
Hello harem.
Hello.
Hi!
What?
I'm early today?
Yes, actually.
I noticed a lot of people, so we don't really stream a lot.
early today yes actually um I noticed a lot of people so like we don't really
stream a lot it's only really me and strawnee that stream on Mondays boomie
just stepped on my keyboard thank you boomie um and so I'm like you know what
I'll stream early just so you know everybody can start their day with some
streams you know um and then I know strawnee's playing bio shock too which
is great uh at 2 p.m. and she's doing that for a couple hours and then at 7
I'll be doing my members stream or I'll be building a gunpla I've never made a
gunpla before hi boomie you can't sit there um I also have fia on my desk she's
purring up a storm she's in a good mood today I was playing with her with a
little ball and she was like real cute it was adorable come on let me um but uh
yeah this was not the present this is not the surprise uh the surprise will be
something else it's something it's uh you'll get it a little bit later probably
after I'm done streaming I have a little bit of a headache today I don't know why
that is let me turn up my physics a bit whoa it's my head gonna pop off no I
think we're good um it'll have to be after this stream um you guys it's not that
crazy it's not that amazing you're like oh my god what is she gonna announce is
like 3d or something no it's not gonna be like that I'm sorry I just got you a small
present that's it yeah yeah I hope you can make the vods I don't mind I'm never gonna
I'm gonna I'm probably not gonna play Sims for super long Toma I'll send you the the the surprise
right now so you can act all giddy and chat wait what did you send me you drew stuff
ooh what is this okay I'll have to read that later I'm sorry I was setting up stream when
we were talking um this is this is the this is the surprise Toma
it's
Toma gets a sneak peek
tell me what you think Toma tell me in the chat 3d Muppet Chibi reveal that would be sick imagine
imagine like all the girls get 3d and we're like yeah we got like Chibi 3d and then like
instead of like me getting like Chibi 3d I'm just a Muppet
no you deal you deal um it's not Muppet related
I might do that if um I know I know uh they know I'm not gonna say anything
but um yeah yeah no well now you guys now you guys can tell
what's it what's it gonna be got something yeah Fia's doing good um fully rendered boomi if I
could get boomi as like I wish YouTube yeah don't tell don't tell Toma shu shu shu if YouTube
could have like throwables like TITS like twitch does that would be amazing because then I would
just have boomi and Fia and Reina as throwables if anybody knows of an equivalent I don't know
if you can do that on like shoest or something um chibi 3d controlling the Muppet hello hi welcome
in hi if you're new here um uh or you're just not used to me streaming this early so maybe you
couldn't only catch like bots and stuff my name is chibi cottonbum I'm your favorite girl failure
dom of jan ones indulge from vealer and I like to be silly and I like to you know what I decided
I'm probably gonna make do a sock puppet making stream ever since the hand cam from yesterday
I think I'm gonna do that I'm gonna make sock puppets of all my gen mates I think that's a great
idea um a custom Muppet is 500 bucks be crown funding that boys no kidding no
no suck my members boomi kaiju fight that'd be sick um but yeah I'm that she be but um it's funny
because I actually used to stream at this time all the time I used to stream at 10 a.m. and um
12 p.m. um so it's actually kind of nice waking up early to get stuff done and then like hopping
on stream early and then I have time to like I need to clean my house I need to send Zumba on a mission
Zumba is my Roomba his name is Zumba and he needs to clean up all the litter that's on my floor
right now boomi what are you doing um but uh Muppet on Throne why you gotta mess with boomi like
that all I want to do is cuddle and sleep I was trying to uh tomah I don't think you noticed this
but I had a lot of typos and when I was messaging you on discord um because boomi was laying on
my keyboard and it was hard for me to like type around him because he was just big plopping on
stuff all right let me actually I'm gonna put I have a neck pillow I'm gonna stick that in the um
microwave because it's like has um essential oils and stuff because my neck hurts
but uh I'm in a good mood today although I need to clean my house
that's pretty it's messy I feel like a mother because I'm taking care of my baby
I put on the cat cam but I am not properly clothed for the occasion so
Zumba versus actually boomi's fine with it he just like stares at it a little bristle excuse me
a little bristle does like choked we'll pick up um the thumbnail is hilarious you like it
I like so like I don't make my thumbnails um I am so lucky to have a management team
and a manager that makes my thumbnails for me um in my schedule for me well I'm like I make my
schedule they just put it together and so they send me that and I'm just like what is this
this thousand yard stare I'm just I'm like this is terrifying are you going to install wicked
whims I was tempted to I was very tempted but I obviously can't play wicked whims on here so I
might actually get wicked whims for um the house of blue I just adopted a pair of kittens and right
now they're tearing apart some paper oh congrats nice job yes adopts don't shop you know always
rescue um I wish I had done that uh before uh because so many cats and kittens are in shelters
and stuff so make sure you if you're considering a cat or a dog or any sort of animal see if they
have one available near you at a local rescue or shelter um inside you there are two mothers one
that takes care of fear the other one takes care of like the tomagotchi where is the tomagotchi
I've actually been taking good care of the tomagotchi it looks like pekora now
it wears a pekora wig let me see what's it up to I checked on it this morning oh it pooped
nice
it's at it's at top happiness and top food I have so much money because I've been playing games
oh yeah shout out to the management yeah boomi and fia are rescued um reina was from a breeder
because we my mom was um pretty allergic to cats and so sime's are a little bit less dandery
so she wanted to go to a breeder um but my mom even herself wishes that she went to a shelter
because she realized she was allergic to reina anyways because reina is weird and she uh still
had a lot of danger although her sister soley who was um no longer with us but she's forever in our
hearts um was not like that like she it was funny okay I got that yeah I like yeah I'm paco mama um
I'm actually I'm mildly allergic to cats myself but only if I like rub my eyes but I feel like
that's anybody um and same thing with dogs fia oh thank you for the lick she licked my nose
she licked my nose earlier she gave me a nose lick
um tall gachis are addictive it'll probably scream at me during stream
yeah I've been like rubbing my eyes all morning that's how I know I need to like
okay boomi I need to um like clean the house because I'm like I probably need the vacuum
song what's the guy's doing they're playing in the tunnel that I got them
um I must now observe that by by the transit property owner says she now has a monkey
don't let the distract her from the fact that paco has a monkey
okay
the monkey's cute though as she has
I wonder what it's like to have I don't know it's such an interesting looking monkey because
it doesn't look like a typical monkey but it's a type of monkey
yeah did you know so I had a friend at my last job who her mom was like an allergy um
specialist or therapist and she was able like you can go to allergy therapy and they'll treat
you for it and usually they can cure you of your allergies and I couldn't I didn't believe her and
she's like oh no I used to be severely allergic to cats and dogs and I have like and I have two
dogs now and I'm like what how does that work they're loud I would probably it's not actually
a monkey it's just pretend I'm still peckering um I think I would probably just buy um stronti what
are you saying stronti's messaging me she's like oh you're streaming never mind um uh I would say
I would probably build a whole like enclosure for it if I had any exotic pets exotic pets are a lot
of money so I build like this whole enclosure for it if I have one which I bet peck or peck or
actually has
blah blah oh tomah just sent me a thing called kudino e-pets
oh I might have to look at that
um
sorry tronnie's like is the model cover up good and I'm like I couldn't find it in the files
please check with the trigger I can't I'm rolling over my headphones hold on you put my headphones on
scan an opossum they're free opossums are sick um I almost like rescue to baby opossum but I didn't
know like because you know at a certain age they leave their mom so I didn't know if I was just
gonna like snag like a random baby opossum that was like supposed to be leaving um but like the
there was like a couple opossum babies just like hanging around and um I'm free and um hi hi welcome
in everyone hi hi welcome in and um opossums what are you talking about opossums are so cute
you I don't know what you're talking about um so
why am I like my shoulders look so broad and high I think I made the model too big in comparison to
my body hold on um but it was like when I was living with my parents it was all my parents
porch there's this little guy and he was just hanging out and I'm like mom can I keep them and
my mom's like no they're a dirty animal and I'm like I could give them a bath and my mom's like no
it probably was rabies and I was like um actually mom did you know that rabies are uh opossums are
one of the few animals that are actually immune to rabies and cannot contract rabies pushes up
glasses uh opossums deserve more love man uh rebranding right now as a possum chuba
where the heck
I just got a big head it's because of my um it's because oh no
wait a second what's happening
hold on please hold
okay that's better it's close to my chin so if I lean back I might have like no neck but it's fine
it's good it's fine actually no that's gonna bother me I'm sorry I'm very particular
yeah
that's as good as it's gonna get I'm just not gonna move that much
I'll lose my head if I wasn't a monkey with a dog in law I'd be some kind of trash animal like
a possum yeah honestly I like think of like um all just like the weirdest animals that I could be
I was like I'm like oh what if there was like
like a vtuber just made of garbage and they're like whole thing is like they were in need
and they were just like they became a vtuber because they were the garbage that was in someone's
room that who played video games all day and then they came to life and then they became
and they're just like covered in garbage and sludge and like they have like a
like a really crusty sock stuck to their hair a bionicle vtuber a sad sad toy story
yeah if Osmond Gold's room came to life yeah like a trash waifu it's a muck pokemon muck
that's like that that's the inspiration that's the inspiration it's pokemon muck
not the sock and it's just made of garbage it's hair is black because of the trash bags
it's not just vtubers in general hey that's not very nice
if someone could make trouble so yeah I'm trying to think would you mind if I steal that idea
oh just credit me or like I wish there was more like lizard because like you'll get like snake
vtubers but you won't have like a lot of lizards I'm like come on what if you were one of those
lizards that shot blood out of its eyes and you just had bloodshot eyes all the time you just never
sleep and you have one of those like it's a I think it's a frilled neck lizard I don't remember
crispy sock here crispy sock there crispy sock wisdom is three hair
all right so today those are horny toad yeah a horny toad
for gen two hello for gen four even
komodo dragon would be sick
I like toads I like toads I like snakes I like um yeah iguanas would be cool
they're like I don't see a lot of turtle vtubers man the horny toad got pushed to gen five no they're
gen four I like turtles or like more food related vtubers oh whoa I just saw a heron
that was so cool there's a heron that just flew by my window what is a heron doing in this area
actually no I think there's a like a little pond nearby that's probably where they're flying to
what the heck um a heron vtuber that would be sick
or like one of those secretary birds like from like from that anime that was really cute
axolotl vtuber when there's like 50 axolotl vtubers too the two the two famous ones I can
think of are elio lotl and um the uh uh the one from pixelink lottie she's cute
imagine the pie feeling oh my god or say so guys or say so I'm gonna say so vtubers um
um so that's a man uh we're not who is this gross looking dude I need to put my headphones on
I still haven't done that oh my god boomie just yelled and ran into the litter box
she's just like I just that was the same energy as like I got a poop and then like running by
and like there's that horse and this girl's like doing some like spiritual crap
I when he told me my music was so freaking loud we're turning that off
I don't know I don't know why he's wearing westafarian colors he's a postafarian
uh so we're making we're making my my my gen mates today guys we're making myself in my gen mates
I'm gonna save myself for last um but I'll have you guys you guys can tell me who you guys want me to do
what did you just say shut up bro boomie wait boomie's talking too I should make boomie in the
cats I'll do that in another stream all right great it's time to create a sim I haven't played the
sims in a really long time I used to play all the time when I was younger um and then my aunt used to
play a lot name gender pronouns aged more cool cool cool cool I really don't need all this I don't
think although there's a lot of stuff new here want me to make I've seen a lot of mercy
all right I think I'm gonna make mercy first um cooking your sim to just their pit well this
is clearly not mercy please can I please just start
maybe I could also though now I have ideas because now I want to make a gender-bent version of all of
us oh but we're okay guys one house before mercies uh yeah because the snippets are going through
withdrawal the senpais need some love so I'll make them right now um and maybe because I'm streaming
an icy slot I can make icy next then Amy then Strani and Azura then me or we'll figure that out
sounds good all right hello my name is mercy can I type okay mercy modist
change pronouns she is she her no I didn't want to change the last name Beltran that's
pretty cool last name maybe strani should just come and just start randomizing stuff to come up
with names for the next gen uh another house of gender-bent versions dealer oh my god
what would the deast it wait no I know what the deast is because I'm like wait um more deast
okay uh but like how do I make them female
this is how do I fix this
how do I can I randomize them
um
that's not mercy
top left
buddy what do you mean oh identity oh okay okay okay I got you that's not mercy that is not mercy
um
a boy named grace um
a feminine lobo okay you know what I think I might start with her she got some eyebrows um
um so obviously she is should we do you make them adults or young adults
and I'll do young adults you know that looks better walk style uh
this is gonna be mercy's walk style
uh the voice
no way
what did she say my what
what
it's mercy
uh
sarpa of a chorg you know that's kind of too girt like I like this one
that sounds like an anime character dub
zarkini enough wait
huh
I don't like that
amigabor
I think that sounds like her a little bit
mercy could have been a shodan protagonist no I'll probably end up giving that voice to like
emi that's okay uh okay so uh her aspiration is obviously love
she's a serial romantic she wants to find the one that's what it is that's yep
mm-hmm
simlish that's like I like finding like songs that are like the original artist records in simlish
I forget what I was listening to I think it was like it was like katie perry and she was singing in simlish
how good is my simlish a warm a bambi
zaba zoo I don't fucking know what he told me
me just talking in tongues
I bet they did uh let's see her preferences
she likes to do activities her activities
excuse me
um let's see because like mercy isn't super into like musical stuff or cooking
I feel like she'd be into handiness for some reason or writing what do you guys think or
no no mischief is definitely for like I see her in me um video gaming I think I might give
the video gaming to Azura just stalking yeah no sewing there's no like um doing that sort of stuff
they have programming and mixology though I guess those are just I'll do handiness
yeah
wait can I do multiple oh I can she can I was just 50
oh what the heck well obviously there's probably more like I don't have any mods installed on this
I'll put video gaming and writing then
cool okay
you you said it you said it mercy
is mixology another word for orgasm there any scissors probably but we should probably keep them away
okay mercy's traits clumsy like myself
uh romantic
geek
oh I'm giving myself the bro I'm so giving myself the bro one
you guys think of geek did I eat yes I ate a bagel ate a cinnamon raisin bagel with butter
I'll do geek
yeah I like it okay
now let's work on her everybody so uh honestly skin tone seems fine
uh her hair people think her hair is actually long in the back she has a ponytail her hair is purple
that's not quite purple uh can I randomize the hairstyle until I get something that I like
oh my god she's me
what this is actually she looked kind of she looked kind of light skin with this look
with the with the baby hairs laid
can this is there a purple color okay I guess that's the closest to purple
maybe I'll do like a nope that's not a side pony
I need is like a long pony in the back
okay this is
uh can I get like some bayang going can I get a little bit of the bayang
oh long oh okay oh so they just I really should have installed mods but yeah okay this looks
kind of close can I give her an eyepatch
I have to give her jealous is jealous a thing can I do jealous is jealous a thing
hello hi reina what are you yelling about
I don't think jealous is a thing
this looks more pink
can I like is there like a color picker oh hi reina
oh my god I can you have her sideshow bob look aren't they twin tails uh no
she does not have twin tails hold on I'm gonna pull up her
her thing I'm a bob right now
uh reina it's very hard to type when you're like on my lap like this
oh hi are you napping
mercy modest
no she has one super long ponytail in the back where is your these girls don't pin their
don't pin their stuff
oh I realize people do draw her with twin tails but she actually does not have twin tails guys
she her uh her scissors is her ponytail holder it just happens to split down the
middle on the back but she has one singular ponytail and people also just draw her with
her hair done in the back that's so funny
there's no wicked whims on my computer guys wait let me see if I can is there like a longer
no that doesn't really work
okay this is as good as it's gonna get because I can't like add more stuff
oh that's this I don't know what that is let's change her face she's a little bit paler than this
yeah okay um see she's more of a neutral tone
yeah that seems about right what color her eyes
I need mercy's freaking it I'm just looking at art on her her twitter
yes they are red you're right
that's the closest I can get to red these aren't gonna be like those hot sims because you
have see you see when you see people with a bilzillion mods installed
his reference are at the oh thank you let me go to my own website the elder
uh agency
see
dot com
talents oh my god it's mercy yeah the promotional art is fine
yeah this is gonna be great value of healer use the assets page in the discord I I don't guys
we're not in the discord um can I get an eyepatch is there eyepatch
okay this is mercy without I kind of want to make mercy with glasses then
because that'll be like the closest thing is mercy with I just feel like glasses
it'll be good because mercy wears glasses sometimes
can I get these stupid ass chocolate bar looking earrings off her though
yeah can I just make her have a knife in her hand
this looks so goofy I need to also make her body type a little bit smaller
oh she's kind of cute when I look at her okay she looking around okay can I get
let me get these stupid earrings off please
I don't know how it's fine
hats
oh perfect
this is mercy what did you say brother yeah I think that's it guys
yeah I think it's DLC I think you're right
unless let me tell you a riddle of a story of a woman so fair
she had scissors in her hair but no one seemed to care
what is this
what
I can make her
I can make her from Star Wars but no eyepatches though okay how do I get how do I take off a hat
okay
accessories get them off except for the glasses I like the glasses glasses are cute it's very her
makeup uh mercy doesn't really wear makeup she's a natural gal let me do her eyebrows actually
can I make mercy oh that'll be in the male house like if I do a male like a gender bent house
like dealer that'll that'll be that um oh arena bye um let me see
how do I do her eyebrows
faces
oh what the heck
these are kind of scary I don't like how big some of these eyes are I kind of like the face she has
I think that looks fine um skin details
no she does not have little eye go teeth oh my god can I give
Amy oh my god I'm so giving Amy a missing tooth um eye details so I need any of that
uh why won't it let me do the eyebrows I could have sworn there was a way to like oh okay
because her eyebrows are black are they
she's very thin black eyebrows no where'd they go
oh
she she she evil
I like that looks good
yeah she knows what's uh you got bunny teeth no I don't have bunny teeth
my teeth are normal I just have ooo ooo mouth on
uh let's do that body oddy oddy sis um one I'm gonna make you a little thinner
uh
muscular to hunt down guys this silhouette is not doing her any favors can I make her more curvy
haha pendo um let's just find a nice full body outfit for her is there like a school girl-ish
oh oh perfect I'm kidding perfect I'll be for like Amy uh oh wait a second hearts no she needs
is like a better skirt than whatever the heck this is what a styled look
no I don't like any of that
uh
I can give her tattoos bodies oh
oh there there you are there's the curve you give her can I give her chest hair
oh my god
yeah
say mercy
um she doesn't have any body scars but that's cool they have that because oh there's like a
c-section scar I thought it was gonna be like more scratches and stuff but uh why do they have
just a c-section I'm putting that on icy anyways since she wants to have a kitten so bad
um medical wearables oh that's cool actually that's actually really neat I have a I have people in
my family have diabetes so they like my dad has a port and stuff not that I'm gonna make my dad and
with Sims but that's actually really cool um let me see outfits so that's can I see bottoms I need
like a good skirt I need a nice short skirt for her
oh my god skirts
is that that's a little bit better I can make it purple wait what's color her skirts
yeah her skirts purple can I change the color
oh okay that's kind of a mood
is there like a more like a school oh wait
this this looks kind of cute I'm not gonna lie to you guys
oh my god casual mercy house three dad deliria I just do have a meet like me and strongy's dad
hold on this is kind of cute guys this is like before mercy before she became like the mercy
house will be two worse than one dad um I kind of like this is there anything similar to that
just in case I'm gonna check
okay let's see if we can give her like some um better socks
she has she wears like loafers she's wearing pumps right now those are probably the shoes
I'm gonna wear um let me give her some flats
what is this put those on icy I can actually probably recolor those to make it look like stuff
um no I don't like those oh perfect these are good um and that's the same color can I do her socks
socks please socks anyone socks accessories
oh no what I can do our nails wait a second though
hold on oh man those are more for me though I'll give her just other fishnets
oh wait that actually might work
that actually might work I wish I could rip them what about these those look goofy as hell
actually is there a different color can I make them like
those look that looks stupid um no I don't I don't like that stop it stop it get some help
or is there like oh oh perfect oh my god perfect oh my god oh my god perfect uh you know what I'm
gonna color her shoes different her shoes are going to be black just to kind of make it oh
god damn oh my god mercy you're so hot holy crap bros
senpai's goon to that brother goon to that what about veeler moms that's a good point
I'm right here
actually I could probably add the socks too because she does have socks with her um with her fishnets
yeah and they're red I wish there was a lighter red color that looks stupid uh a little black
just so it's a little bit more coherent because that just looks random with the red
although it matches her glasses but I'm gonna do black
um let's give her some really nice nails
her nails I think are red
like no I think they're purple I'll do purple this is kind of cooking
guys I think I'm cooking
I think this is mercy guys I think she's kind of hot would you
you would you
yeah can I make her butt bigger
oh my god I can
why can I do that
let me make her front yeah that's better
and her boobs could be a little smaller don't say oh and I'm grabbing your oh oh oh my god
I'm I'm gonna go feral I think that's good
can I make her
can I make her thighs thicker I'll put them back
of course real mercy is better this is as good as like I'm gonna I'm gonna get in the sims
is there if there's any sims fans out there and you guys like who who mod stuff can you make us in
the sims please because that'd be sick okay that'll be mercy
wait no I'm not done how do I add more oh okay
all right who are we doing next that's a man um
hello I hate this who is that stop
she looks kind of cute but that's not what we're looking for
mitzel bin narla oh wait no I said I was gonna do uh I see because I took her slot today so I'll
do I see hello my name is I say snow paws I see snow paws so this will be for the snowberries watching
I was I put snowberries
snow pass oh a house where I do and then I could make another house full of um
our mascots like the male version
oh my god I can make a house with the male version of our mascots and then I can make
them marry each other oh my god oh my god oh my god I'll make her a teen the game froze
she's she's 18 guys um
and then who who wants they are married yep yep only when they're married um let's find
what's the campfire that is not mercy
kambibba womberg what that that sound like Azura's voice
oh that's Azura's voice
sar pava mesa plim sar pava mesa plim sar pava holy night mokosa
oh nea loray sapoma wabasi wait
some boom in a wash
she gore from amica till i womberg
that that's that's that's ivy's voice
that's missle bin narla
I think that's the closest I'm gonna get uh what's what's her walk her walk is going to be
she she's a she's sleepy so she that's her walk
she she she doesn't hibernate
wo bossy you know boss yep that's it um
um should I make us all sisters
no that wouldn't really make any sense for genetic stuff uh household member yeah that's fine um all
right queen icy you know I need to change her hair while I do this let me make her hair
short
okay medium then because that's too short
she looks like an old woman what the frick is this
and I'm giving her pigtails wait no that would be for Emmy hold on uh
oh my god what are these Karen ass haircuts though
oh these are so ugly
oh my god I will all change her face very fast
do light blue I can't do light blue there's only turquoise blue
so I have to make it white because that's the closest I can do I should just give her ban two knots
okay you know what I'm just gonna keep it like that for now she looks like she looks weird right now
it's fine
okay she has no no that's a Karen haircut you're not wrong hold on uh
I'll keep it like that then I don't know she's looking like a freaking Targaryen
let me just change her face because it's bothering me
uh can I randomize her face
that's a no that's not gonna work
that kind of looks right her neck looks a little
why is her body looks so weirdly proportioned
I was hoping when I randomize the face it would randomize all her features
because this will just randomize the skin tone
I'm blue da ba dee da ba daa
I hate that what is that face
what is happening why is I see the hardest to make so far
ew okay hold on let me do this face
yeah that looks cool uh whatever uh anyways let's just zoom in
you know what look turn that way I see while we do this
well madam cook uh I don't I don't know we'll have to see um let's see I think for her
what should her aspiration be
I feel like it should be like family should be like nature because she's from
God quest
I think it should be family yeah family she wants a big happy family yes
and then her preferences music duh um she likes all music winter holiday music yes
what is s-pop is that supposed to be like k-pop but simlish
new pop music kids radio lullabies hip-hop electronical carnival beats um I don't
know if she likes alternative but we'll give her alternative
she's just dancing when we're not looking at her
yeah it's again remember this is like all the basic stuff I don't have any mods um she is going to be
I feel like she should be hotheaded because she's a bear
uh music lover
oh there's the jealous one jealous
oh I couldn't see that before oh I might have to go back to mercy to that
let's put it instead of geek let's do jealous there we go
yeah I see hotheaded
yeah let's do hotheaded
when she I'm playing games with her and she's like rage just out off off stream but it's like
so cute because she's like I fucking hate I can't even do it she's so cute when she's angry I like
it's just funny to watch um change her skin tone she's much paler uh she's definitely cool tones
just give her blue eyes eye details no I want to change her eye color
beautiful blue eyes I don't understand this kind of butt chin that she has going on I kind of don't
like that now she has like a freaking like no chin so let me fix that
that's better perfect
okay nose a little bit smaller
yeah I I see like smaller features for her why do these lips look so kissable
that's all I'm gonna say no that's not right no no no no no no no no
yeah
Sam a starian shut up it's not a starian oh I like those lips I kind of picture her as being like
yeah I think those are the ones that I started with but it's fine um
okay let me up to change her out can I make her like shorter
can I make her okay get those booba out of here um
she got some thick thighs so we'll do that yeah
yeah she got the she got the Pixar mom build okay let me just
make those a little bit smaller
um I could give her a dress like make her like cute see but I'm gonna try to like
do people's outfits hold on let me go to ic's although ic's might be a little goofy looking
if I try to put a vest on her I don't know if there's any vest what if I do
because it might be under something masculine
oh I think she looked cute in a little crop top to be honest
if I ever make the pin pals you guys are getting the gay the pride flag
um what fair fair
is there really like no vest there's like this it actually kind of looks cool but it's not
really her she's not like rocker there's the vest that just looks silly fair oh wait no where the
tops go uh is there like a bear shirt that'd be cute locked is that jesus on that shirt
can be punisher this kind of goes with the kind of theme can I like change the color of her shorts
and give her like spats
this is hard guys this one's hard
I don't need just feminine shorts just like show me everything oh wait what's this
that looks fine
pay 60 dollars to unlock jesus are ic's eyes orange oh my god you're right
I don't know why I immediately thought that she just should have blue eyes
can I
well I can't give her orange eyes okay then she has light brown eyes is there like a way to
give her like crazy colored eyes no again this is the base game so she's gonna have light brown eyes
um let's change her shoes
all right okay so she has
okay so she has she actually wears tights ever get that are ripped um but let me get her like
some big thick um boots those are kind of cute actually oh she's looking she's looking better
guys I think she's looking better um let me get her some sockies
yo
bros it's kind of coming together
I see it I see the vision
I kind of wish I gave these to mercy oh I know she has fishnets in the thing never mind those
don't make sense um what are these nails I don't know what these nails no let me look at her nails
let me look at her funny nails
I gave her like silver nails can I give her like
yeah those are gross oh light blue is cute yeah like that oh yeah that's a that's a mood guys
hello I wish I could like layer stuff
I'll put a ring on her finger
because the snow so the snowberries be staying married to her she's married where is it there it is
married to the daddas how are we feeling daddas this is as good as I can't make her shorter
can I
is there a way to I think there's a way I can make her shorter I just don't know how to do it
oh I think it's edit detail mode
I don't know man look at that badonk oh wait she has like a let me just flatten her tummy out
real quick damn mama zam only with mods okay hold on let me make sure I can make her
can I like go into detail edit mode for those come on you're telling me I can't make her
tatas smaller oh I can make them higher higher whoa small high and small that's cute
kind of gives the illusion of flatness
all right I think that's I see you guys I think that's I see hold on let me look at her picture
again can I get her some gloves are there gloves I can get her
that just looks stupid no we're not doing that wait did her nails polish go away I can't tell
no she still has it okay I think that looks fine can I give her like some some like body scars
body skin details yo oh wait I should be I forget I can change all of their like the
seasonal outfits frick I have to go back and do that for mercy um
I can't really tell what some of these are that's just a birthmark
give her them chaga stripes give her them a lightning no she doesn't need that um okay I
can't really do it's kind of cool they have birthmarks and stuff
I'm giving her I'm giving her the c-section scar bros from all those kittens you guys are putting
in her there's probably more body scar mods okay wait she doesn't need that
actually that kind of works I might leave that there I kind of I might leave that there
because it works in the place of the scar and a thigh um yeah that's fine
yeah all right let's do I'm gonna quickly I'm gonna do the pre-made ones ew ew what is that
what is that
honestly but you know what that's Icy's formal style
ew what is up with this gross lipstick on her
I kind of like this
um what about the the sporty shorty
all right fine that's good too um
down the rabbit hole no that should be for me if it's called down the rabbit hole
uh let's see oh my god tom baby shorty peach that sounds so freaking cute
yes uh oh my god yeah that's I'm I'm just quickly doing the stylized looks just to keep stuff
on the hunt what is she a cougar Jesus
oh mommy I see
no you can't wear that I see your no you can't you can't wear that this is better for you get
rid of this stupid ass hat though give me get let's get rid of this stupid hat
get rid of the hat we don't need that that's that's stupid the dress however I like it
is there another dress is there like another what are these like early 2000s freaking dresses dude
is there like another color can I make it like oh my god that's so cute okay that's fine
uh let's see bathing suit no
are there like accessories for the swimwear
because I I like this
that's kind of cute I can't hear what I want mom
how are we gonna give straddle your hair I will have to like think of something for that
uh I kind of like the sunglasses it's kind of a mood can I give her like crazier sunglasses
because I feel like she'd wear crazy sunglasses yes no actually can I make them blue that's better
uh is there like come on are there accessories
are there other because I would give her a I would give her an inner tube I'd be honest
I'd give her an inner tube if I could
yeah half the clothing on this in this game is how we do you do fellow kids
all right uh what about what is this gross makeup on her face um hot weather outfit
can can I go back
rock angel I'd be emmy um I think can I just like randomize
I kind of like her wearing a bikini top if it's hot outside because I feel like she would do that
because she's a bear or like this no I like the bikini top or the bikini top go give me the bikini
top let's make it blue let's give her her spats back
I just sneezed on reina I'm so sorry
she hopped over my desk and I just sneezed on her
I think I like those let's make them black and uh yeah okay oh can I please just change her makeup
what is that ew girl take this makeup off your face
I don't like it no makeup for you you can do like some blush and that's it you're too young
sheiks where's the blush that's cute face pink let's add a little bit
can I do like a light okay that's cute
oh my god that's kind of a mood uh all right let's fix her little tozies let's give her some
uh I don't really see her wearing a lot of heels
let's give her some cute flats
it's kind of in blue oh that's adorable thank you thank you for the bless use
or arm floaties yeah exactly why are there that's probably a thing in like the other game
all right this is terrible please let me get rid of her freaking makeup stop it
why do you give her this ugly makeup
all right stylized look what for cold water what is this that's so ugly okay it looks like
I'm gonna do I like the hat the hat the hat can stay is there
yeah the hat can stay I think that's kind of cute let's give her I think I like the big sweater
or wait where's that little jacket where's the jacket
no blouses so the the suit jackets but but but oh bras
okay there was literally oh this is actually cute yep that's it that's that's the move
is there something that like kind of matches more
okay maybe we don't give her the hat are there ear muffs
that's cute let's give her a white like a gray one okay get these stupid
outfit stop with these pants she's gonna wear shorts still because that's just her
she's always forever wearing shorts and I'll give her
I need like some really goofy looking boots actually these will work because those look
like her shoes or these ones that's cute what is that is that a rabbit with tats that's funny I
like it she's representing me all right I like that that's kind of a look where are the jorts
five pretty bags uh let me put some um leggings on her again
no I don't care about if they're cold whether or not
they're under socks
that's cute I'm pretty sure I've worn this outfit myself I love bomber jackets okay let me do
mercies real quick hello mercy this might take longer than I thought
I'm only two girls in
I'm only two girls in and it's almost been two hours
mercy this is not it sweetie uh I like
oh my god that is so seductive this looks like I think that would give that to Azura um I think
this in purple actually there must be better dresses in this
I need a better dress I'm pretty sure my mom has worn that dress what the heck um
stop with the like the random labels are annoying I like that that's cute can I get it in purple
yeah let's give her some red shoes yeah perfect
all right sports
what is that outfit
you know what I think I would give mercy that oh what are the other ones yeah no mercy's having
that one um I feel like mercy would wear a really cute baby doll like this indeed uh what's the colors
give her purple and then let me change bunny slippers no I'll give her normal slippers I'll
give myself bunny slippers um and the red or purple yeah that's better they don't match though
let's do black because the black matches the straps is there like a cuter sleepwear
no I meant outfits
mercy
nice wait isn't that your yeah that's more so probably like mine uh okay I think that looks
uh okay I think that looks fine
uh party full but that's so stupid no um party outfit
would be a good party outfit for her
oh my god
that just looks like me um
beauty in the this is cute oh yeah yep that's it right there perfect I like that that's cute for
mercy what is why is she wearing a durak bro oh my god
why is the durak has baby hairs I'll give her a bonnet uh no why is a bonnet in swimwear that's
not right that's not right bro that's that's not very nice um get rid of that
you see tops I think I'm gonna mix a match for her that's cute
actually I feel like mercy would be modest is there a one piece
she wear a cute sassy one piece is there a better color
that's just boring
uh nope I don't like that that's cute yeah she would be modest I think it's funny when people
pronounce her last name mercy modest it's modis uh hey me I don't want you walking around barefoot
but you know it's fine girl what the hell
I feel like you know what she can wear like a
I like that that's that'll work um
um
no no that's not I don't understand why they don't have better better looks let's give her a cute
pullover I can't change the color then I like that one more um pants pants pants pants
pants pants revolution oh they're like
can we just give her some like that's what pants yeah she'll be cozy she'll be cozy when
it's winter she's wearing a cute little jumpsuit you know what I like it all right we finished
mercy and I see cool we need to tell this man
a motion halt damage okay let's do uh emi next no we said strawnee that's right strawnee then emi
uh add new sim
bro what the fuck are you
what is it oh no I see I see look look look look look look I made you cute this isn't your main
outfit let me make your I'll show you your main outfit see that's that's as good as I could get
okay look I gave you a dumpy
I can't wait wait what happened if I did no I think that would mess it up if I like
turned you I made you teen
because then we'd have to raise you
okay uh well that's definitely not strawnee
uh can I please change this
the news I can add why is her skin look like that that looks really like purply
sure
oh no I can't say that
that's just like me when I wake up
actually no I usually don't wear a bonnet
actually I see the wear bonnet too bad
none of these are strawnee coated
slow vejila damn girl
oh girl
no that isn't that fit is not it
you look like a creepy therapist that prays on her patience
can I give her
ew I want to can I give her a Scottish accent
and a gom schloaf man
no I need a good base
welcome welcome new member award a pulp
god please
that was just a different body type you put on her
it's me if I tease out my hair
that looks like strawnee to me
night hits fat tires please I'm trying to come up with a good base
but none of these these are all brown women which strawnee is not
perfect that's her all right night hits big arse hold on let's give her the big arse
there we go perfect she's not pregnant can I all right perfect
um so for strawnee I can give her green hair
I can give her green hair
that looks stupid uh I think I might
ew um
that looks really scary that also that's actually kind of looks like her hair why
is her face look like that though I might need to fix her face
fuck with the melon
yeah she does that's why she hired two brown girls ladies and gentlemen you heard that
here first oh actually this might work or maybe that one no actually that might work
because then the smaller ones the smaller pigtails I could give to Emmy
or I can just make her look like this this is kind of seductive
a little swoop what do you think strawnee I don't know maybe
it's the ball talk
I can't read
texture melon
no no
no it's been sucked from me no what do I do I don't know
oh my god okay let me go
oh my god
okay we'll just give her
we'll give her that no I just don't like how that looks it just looks weird maybe it's her face
it must be your face oh or it's your body if it ain't your body then it must be your face
girl what
all these girls look perpetually terrified I might just give everybody the same face
okay let me make you white again she's she's pale milk ew that's not the right color
that sounds bad
I'm so sorry
yeah okay I'll make her neutral toned because she's not as cool as I see what I can I can slide to
customize the color what
okay
or I can really make her dead
no this looks like sour milk that sound I should shut up that sounds so bad
never I'm just gonna stop talking that sounds so racist I'm so sorry
all right let's just do strotties
hold on she's she's a little bit too thick oms
yeah
as big as I can make your butt safely your arms are so long for no reason
your arms usually are like up here why are your arms so long
uh can I do like her body
tight
y'all mama yeah let's just do that all right
hey strontie how's it going what color are your eyes again purple
so I can give her purple eyes but I can't give orange eyes to icy doesn't make any sense
um
you want to be stuck around with that bbl
it's a creepy ass teeth um so for her
what should stronties um aspiration be I think perhaps family and then have a successful lineage
I think that will be it it was nature
that would just be everything about fishing and that's the opposite so I think family with
she wants her people to succeed popularity no she doesn't care about popularity
um
hobbies
video gaming
excuse me rockets uh let's give her rocket science you know what just because
comedy I know she's a cuttlefish and she's trying to save the oceans but I'm gonna put
fishing just so you can see her by the water can I make strontie perpetually pregnant no
actually well probably no why are her boobs big get get rid of those things I can't believe you
can't make them flatter than that to be honest there's all this like body stuff in here but
you can't make them super flat um all right so let's say she is
let's see
let's do loves outdoors
family oriented
and then
I think I'll put self-assured or ambitious
this
ambitious
steps maybe
how noi noi noi noi all right let's fix her face so she doesn't look so much like I see
her
I can't tell who's talking I think it's reina
what are some of these eyes I don't Jesus seeing into your freaking soul
I make them a little bit smaller
pretty sure that was the original ones I started with but that's fine
um no okay put them back I just
Jesus I hate
it's kind of terrifying
fun fact my ex-wife because my son cheated on her that's terrible I'm so sorry
oh my god it's kind of funny at the same time no I'm sorry it's so bad giant eyes for hypnotizing
let's give her like a thinner brow
that looks very mischievous
where is it that's actually so I like that one
why does that look like a like a villain eyebrows
oh my eyes are itchy
let's give you a little bit of makeup
other stylized looks
I'm okay she's not like heavy on the eye makeup now guys come on where did it go
she kind of looks like a goth mommy and I'm kind of for it
I kind of like that where's the eyeshadow that I can get rid of it
it's kind of cute I kind of like the the eyeliner like that
exchange your nose up
no no
kind of like the original nose I had but I don't know which one it was maybe that one
she was starting to look like baby doll from sucker punch
oh you know what I forgot to do I forgot to do her walk
strawberries walk
she walks goofy
no
mm-hmm
I think I like I think I like the
yeah I think I like that goofy cuttlefish I like that because it has the spirals
that's not even goofy she's just hunched over
she made them enemies after we broke up that's so scary
yeah we got cool okay she'll get the goofy walk then let's do her voice
I'm trying to go strong his voice right now I know she's about to start streaming
so if there's reeflings in the chat of course thank you for stopping by you can go say hi to
moment because I'm I do want to get through making all of us beforehand stream
we both say you say that's a nice war bow that doesn't give the charm
what
I can't add a Scottish accent
I could have two tabs open thank you I appreciate it
very hypnotic goofy walk indeed
I don't think I'm ever gonna get shiny's voice because none of them are gonna sound like her
because of the accent all right anyways let's continue working on her face
she's very cute she looks better no those lips are not it
it's hard to think of them as like non-anime women and like what type of lips they'd have
because they'd all just be like this it was that this was you're being real
this can I gender
okay those are fine
I don't want to give her a little thinner face
or how do I do her cheekbones because her cheekbones look a little bit
like
okay
that kind of makes her look like she has a double chin oh no she doesn't
I think it's just a shadow looks okay
okay
what is up with that freaky smile though I don't like
she constantly has that on her face from the reeflings
uh let's do a little
can I make it more subtle actually
that's cute oh wait I need to get the stuff off her face
what is this just cony confetti
oh my eye is watering
oh
I'm chip stealing eyes
it's me I'm the Batman
okay maybe it'll start looking like her let me change her outfit so I'll do stylized looks
her everyday look should be Leia
no um well what's shawty's everyday look be
she's wearing a kimono
or a yukata is there a yukata it'll just look like a that no that's Korean
it'll just like a woman like a white woman cosplaying as an asian woman I don't know if I like that
oh my god
yeah that's a hanbok yeah
yukata with the swimsuit
you know what I think I might just have her have a swimsuit on at all times her lingerie
yeah where's the swimsuits
is that it
show me all the swimsuits
this is such a stupid outfit
t-shirt with no pants that's a good point I could do t-shirt with no pants yes I know there's not a
yukata guys I know there's there's only this everything but like a kimono or a yukata
uh
or is a t-shirt
can I give her just an apron
can I give her just a giant t-shirt please
that looks bad what oh okay that looked so bad oh my god oh my can I please oh my god
where are the where the bottoms that looks so bad that looks so bad thank you
is this look at now miwa it's not
that looks bad uh let's give her cool um everybody say hi to miwa
it's on us let's get rid of those shoes she walks around barefoot
um
I think that's cute
okay
just give her a goofy t-shirt and just lace panties
how do I make her barefoot perfect
I don't like this why can't I make this bigger rena what are you doing
wait I think I can actually make her every day sleepwear where is the sleepwear
what there's vests
um
blouses
that looks stupid
can I just give her a big giant sweatshirt oh that's cute actually oh it's machino too that's
cute can I do a different color no
where is the sleepwear stuff I can't find it full body
okay
let's give her an oversized oh I wish it was a solid color costumes
what is that
I kind of want to give her this other different colors I was going to say if it's in green then
it's a sign I could see I could see okay lesbians make a child I think so I don't know
what is this outfit I don't understand what that's from
just with her toes out
we're both gays I'm pretty sure
can I just put her in a robe
because she's always wet she's just in a robe
okay
what I can't make her every day just like walk around in a
wait because it's full body what if I do swimsuits
and I give her like
a green okay that's green green
I wish I could give her like
wait sorry hold on don't look at her don't look at her don't look at her dumpy um can I do like a
I wish I could like layer a jacket again that's definitely for
oh strutty
actually that might work
a little some pants
can I give her like that looks stupid um can I change the color
she just walks around just naked
yeah I think I might do a giant hoodie because I'd like I'm like
what would what would she what would a girl like her
let's give her the oversized machino hoodie or is there a green one no there isn't that pisses
me off but there are some green ones that just looks stupid it also looks stupid
well
she'd wear black and um
yeah this is as good as it's gonna get guys I can't the straw he's just very hard
she's just yeah and then yeah and she can get a little peek a dumpy get a little butt thing
yeah let's do her toes she has a french manicure on her toes
because strawny loves her french manicures too bad I can't give her one they're just gonna be
white then she got cute white toes and can I give her a french manicure on her hands
oh I can okay
I can't tell what color they are can I scroll down
that looks stupid green you know it's kind of a mood yeah we'll have it match your hair
all right that's her every day that's her every day guys it's every day bro with that Disney channel
flow what is this trash what's her formal outfit it's not that
we will put
her in that's cute actually
I kind of want these are not flattering on figures that she looks like come on all right there we go
because I'm like where are these curves at bro where are they at though
okay that works um athletic she I feel like she would wear this outfit yes that's cute perfect
is that the is that griffin door what is that on her hat it doesn't matter um
um
no she's not she would not wear anything we all know this um
she's wearing that
I kind of see her wearing that and then just like and then I feel like she would wear bunny slippers
just to just to do that
siren dress yes
I like she was so I don't know maybe I don't know I think that's cute that's kind of a look
all right party this is not what she's wearing to a party that's what I can tell you she's on the hunt
huh
no straw knee would wear this
yeah no she'd wear that she'd wear that yep yep yep yep can I do it in like
yeah that's better that kind of goes with their colors more
in terms of that uh
huh these are all bad
well I'm just saying
what are up with some of these swimsuit tops bro
okay she looks she looks good in white white goes well with her hair
so she's gonna
she's wears her underwear
no let's not see that
why is that like a speedo why did her like gooch get bigger when I put that on her
you see that her goosey came out well let me make her a little bit thicker good
what's up with that where'd her butt go thank you
wait is her ass gonna get bigger in the different outfit
okay no I thought it would be funny if her ass just changes
if it's hot weather you know that's kind of cute
her toes are always out though we've we've established this except for the formal but
she'll she'll walk barefoot around
bigger or I'm glad it's a treat um let's see let's do green that's cute she's walks around like that
um cold weather that's actually kind of cute but we're not giving her pants
no pants no pants allowed
I kind of see her just wearing an oversized hoodie and then thigh highs
oops
where's the thigh highs at well not let me pick
oh it's there under socks I keep forgetting
I feel like she would just wear
that's really cute
it doesn't make sense but it's cute okay that's all I can say
oh I can't do both I could have sworn I could do both I guess not
sure all right that's scrawny everybody
next one up pin pals you've been waiting for this
it's Emmy
I'm ready
it means I mean strontis is hard to do because I think hers is the least like
um
like how can I like non-fantasy design aside from azuras
can Addison be a story I don't know how that works
uh I think that looks perfect uh so I think we're moving on I think we can move on to Azura
I think Emmy looks great
oh my god I can't do like I can't make them small guys and what it makes
because that's just like kind of problematic I won't lie so I'll make them jeans
it looks like it was the same guy but he just put out an outfit so people couldn't recognize him
came off perfect that's me
oh my god
Rena's falling asleep on my desk he's about to fall
also Emmy these all look like Emmy so far
actually can I go back because I want that face
yeah she looks mischievous let's get let's get rid of the fade though let's let's get rid of that fade
she looks freaking demonic
I'll call her Emmy's eyes they're also like reddish purple yeah they're over X is red
um so they give her I hate the freaking smile
can I give her
I want to give her freckles
where are the freckles the freckles is the first thing
there's no freckles it that doesn't make any sense well the skin details are there and
I don't see any freaking freckles I see beauty marks oh there we go I was about to say I was
about to be like what the hell bro I was about to be very upset
I can't put a band-aid on her nose
Emmy Emmy men with um change her eyes her eyes should be a little bit bigger she has big eyes
I can give her the I should make her their faces more proportionally down here because apparently
that's the this is the face size of consent but down here is not
this is abomination
no I want to make her eyes farther apart
can I make them smaller again please
oh my god why do they have Joker smiles stop
you
kind of like the pout all right hold on let me oh my name is Emmy kiss your sister
kiss you
uh deviance chief of mischief public enemy
me
villainous valentine she wants to destroy the love lives no she's gonna be chief of mischief
jimmy bisu that'll be for the dealer house um yeah that sounds about right to me they're dastardly
their mean interactions are very bad why is that I didn't pick that did I no I want this one
oh it does it automatically I don't get to pick like this okay um color
no I don't really care about that uh we'll do painting is one of our main things
and piano of video gaming writing I don't know if she can play guitar mischief
yeah that's good
oh because she's because she's a teen they don't have as many stuff as the other girls
she looks like ginger slender listen that's just as good as it's gonna get
uh childish now I should have given that to I see wait what did I give to I see
wait oh she's a young adult
I might I thought I made her a teen okay music okay
okay
because I'm like wait why did she have three
I can't change her that's not up to me I can't change the arm length I can't do that
can I
okay that doesn't matter um it's not the priority she is going to be
creative and
do
kleptomaniac um let's see
hate children no uh I think I'll do art lover
yeah perfect
if you had wicked way I guys I can't play wicked whips on you
I'll do that on the house of blue because then I would totally do that if I'll probably
like I'd probably download more mods and like make us all again
and then do weird stuff
yeah that's a friday stream kind of deal I agree uh okay I mean we gotta fix you girly pop
uh we also have to give you a different outfit because I can't just give you fishnets in a vest
for your outfit your shirt um
I think I'll actually give her this one
no what the makeup looks so bad okay
don't forget the hello kitty what do you mean
oh my god what family with wicked whims oh my god guys that might be uh like uh like uh
sims and hoony pot might be the games we play the first few times for um for that
uh
I don't really know what else to do with her I'm just like I don't know man like I can't
really do a lot with her um because like they don't have again there's no mods it's with the
basic vanilla sims 4 so I can't do a lot which is a bummer because I'm making them crazy
let's do formal that's not it that is not it for formal I'll tell you that much
ear piercings Amy doesn't have ear piercings but it kind of goes with that
she's she's a goth queen we all know this oh I accidentally dropped something
here
why have you been modding
oh wait you got some that was just like what for the chat um okay let's do stylized looks
I kind of want to give her
the same
I think I want to give her this oh my god MES queen go off sis go off what about red
I kind of like it in red
black fits better though that'll be her her formal outfit
she looks like such a dork um
um
why does she have her ear ring aid
I think I'm gonna give Amy this outfit minus a hat get the hat off get rid of the hat
she's so long I don't know what to fix
why did they all look like slender man
sorry Amy you have to be aboard that's how things are
make them super high
sorry
along Amy
yeah it's topa I do what do you help with that oh my god
oh all right so for Amy what she's gonna wear for sleep
is she's just gonna wear a t-shirt because that would be just about right yeah t-shirt
is there another shirt oh that's cute um yeah I think she wore it a crop top and like some
cute panties
no that's not earlier that's fine can I change the color of these make them white
she wore some whitey tidies to bed or alternatively
that kind of works no slippers dogs are out
she's been a long game this is stretched out Amy hold on let me fix her face because her
face is kind of weird her like cheeks are a little like
no put it back
okay her face looked she looks so weird okay let me just give her a little bit more
meat on her bone so she just looks like a stick because Jesus Christ
can I make her feet cute
I can give her huge feet can I give her little dainty toes I can give her just paws to walk on
how do I make her feet back to normal I can't tell okay I think that's best
the slip
waist snatched
okay uh that's her sleep outfit part what is this dumbass outfit
I think she would have like the same outfit
no never mind I lied I was gonna say the same outfit as I see I just hate this hat so much
get rid of it um
let me see if I can get her a different dress
that looks stupid that looks too she needs a cute short dress
that's cute
make an orange to match her hair oh I should have given her these boots for her every day
I kind of like that that's kind of cute all right or I could make a green to match her
dress that she just made for herself I can find it where the heck did the dress go
no that looks a little weird I'm gonna keep it orange
she's so skinny
oh let's see hello hi thank you
okay swimwear you know that kind of works for her I'm getting rid of actually I kind of like
the sunglasses on her can I get her different sunglasses
yes queen go off queen
she's so skinny you can make her just a square
no we're snatched we're snatched in this house
oh my god
I don't understand what is this stupid bracelet on her get rid of that
well actually if it's a different color I'll do that yeah that's cool actually
all right I wish I could give her a bandaid on her nose
hot weather hot weather she's just gonna wear a t-shirt
hot weather t-shirt
that's so stupid looking um
this looks so bad
you're playing for a room why is it me so hard too I can't it's strontium in the heart
can I
wait can I change the color does it make it
when it's hot outside see where's the pride shirt
in in support of the pin pals why am I so hard
hi for you
I like that she's just wearing underwear
oh
yeah that's what she wears during hot weather
oh it's just converse
oh wait I never did her voice
no
dogs
along
so
well
geen
I like that one. Yeah, non-modded sims are something else. Okay, let's fix this yee-yee-ass
outfit. Cold weather, she's wearing...
I don't like the cold weather looks like... What is she wearing in cold weather, boys?
Wait, I feel like... Am I missing one? No.
This is actually pretty... Oh, I forgot to give her fishnets.
Actually, no, she doesn't have fishnets. Her fishnets are on her chest.
This kind of works. Get rid of this gross ass makeup, though. No.
No. Not it. The skirt? Whack. Whack. The skirt is whack.
Okay, I kind of hate this.
Perfect, Emi. She's ready for a night on the town.
That's cute. I see you wear that. Yeah. Can I change her to like some crazier boots?
Just give her demonias. When it's snowing outside, that actually works. I'm down.
Ah, I'm stretching.
All right, it's kind of a mood. All right, Azura.
I was like, why do I feel like I'm forgetting someone? It was myself.
Because I was like, wait, there's Azura, but who else? Let's do Azura.
Should I make Azura an old lady because she's ancient?
Azura, what happened to you?
You know what? Damn, Azura, you still got it.
What? No, she's going to be a young adult.
This character is very ethnically ambiguous.
Gosh, no, you look very annoying for some reason. You look like someone I'd meet at a theater
event and you would not stop talking about how you helped out behind the scenes.
Okay, this kind of works. What color is Azura's hair? Her hair is mint.
That's as good as it's going to get.
Let me change her skin tone a little bit.
Can I change her outfit while I'm at it just so I can see what the heck I'm doing?
Because I'll make her fig. This is not, this figure is not working for her. Let's just do that.
All right, that's Snatched Waste, Big Booba, Thicc.
Okay, she's not, she's, yeah, there we go.
Hold on, fix that dumpy.
Heal. I can't make her boobs any bigger.
I can make him sack here. Let's give her some perky, perky fangs. Yeah, she's queen.
Every day I see you get cuter than the last. Oh, that's impossible. I probably get more annoying.
All right, oh, let's make her, uh, that kind of seems right.
Neutral tones.
This is, this is how people draw black people in the vtuber community. That's how they color them.
This, that, or this, or alternatively.
I'm just looking for gray tones. Frick.
I remember I would ask for a tan if people would send me this, and I'm like, this is weird.
Oh, okay, let's do a little bit. She's definitely more warmer tones, but she's not orange. I don't,
maybe, no, that makes her look freaking green.
The fact that it's hard to get her freaking skin tone. Okay, I think that's the closest one.
Yeah, it's interesting. And especially like lighting-wise, they, they struggle with skin tones.
Um, she's actually a little bit lighter than that, I realize. She's actually this skin tone,
but we'll make her a little bit darker. Or I could try to find her actual skin tone.
I don't really think, I like, I know I won't be able to find my actual skin tone.
None of these match me. None of these match Azura's natural skin tone either.
Um, okay, let's just go back to this one.
Can I like, yeah, use a color picker? Yeah, usually that's why, like, we offer palettes on our,
like, I'm getting an updated ref sheet with my tan, and so I'm gonna, like,
you can just, people can just color pick it from the picture, but they never do.
Oh, if the tone's wrong, at least for me, if you're commissioning it for Azura,
then, um, I think me and Azura kind of both understand that nobody's probably gonna get
our skin tone right. It's very rare when someone does. Um, but you know, sometimes there's really
good skeb artists that gets, like, uh, on my PL, they got my skin tone right. And sometimes they
just made me white. It's funny, more, the more people I commissioned on, I've commissioned
for my PL, when I was Rena on Vigen, made me white, and she was even lighter than how I am now.
Or, like, around the same skin tone, and people would just, like, make her, like, green. I don't
like what's happening. Doesn't the slide do anything? I don't, it kind of just makes it lighter.
Like, yeah, it doesn't really do much.
All right, we'll just, we'll do that. It's kind of a mood. Excuse me.
Why can't I type? Cap lock on.
Let's find a deeper tone. No.
That sounds like a zero when she gets really happy and excited.
When she does, like, a goofy voice when she's, like, doing,
is our child still, like, yes, our child's doing fine.
Yeah, yeah, it's difficult. Yeah, that's a good point. Sometimes that they,
they do a shadow or a highlight or, like, a lighter portion instead of just, like, the flat.
Zarkiny and a fliss.
Wait, I got her voice really good before.
That just sounds like Deku.
It sounds really close.
Oh, Azura, stop, behave.
Be Vos Febene.
It sounds like goofy.
It's weird because between here and here it just sounds like...
I kind of like that. I think that's as good as it's going to get.
Azura's walk. I think she'd have a perky walk.
Yeah, what's this stuff? That'll be my walk.
I naturally, like, walk really bouncerly, I've been told.
What is snooty walk? That's stupid.
No, yeah, I like the perky walk. For Azura, a hundred percent.
All right, for Azura, naturally, it's family and to have as many children as possible.
We all know this.
Activity cooking.
She burns everything. I wanted to frown on cooking.
She doesn't like cooking.
She likes fitness. She does like fitness a lot.
Mischief.
Painting. Video gaming.
Yeah. Oh, there's different... I can add more? Purple.
I didn't know I could do that for everybody.
Damn it. It's fine.
Lullabies.
I actually don't really know the music that Azura's into.
Romance.
World.
Common little mama.
Because he always says, shut up. Shut up. No.
Shut up about my... I don't always walk on my tiptoes.
I usually walk on my tiptoes to be quiet or if I'm avoiding stepping on stuff in my messy house.
What don't you understand?
Let's see.
I'll make her a cup of boll.
That's literally her though.
Who am I sneaking by? Yeah. My cat's boomy so he doesn't assassinate me.
Let's do foodie because we all know she likes to whore people.
Oh. Oh, shit. Architects are gonna love that.
Put our maker a vegetarian.
And also make our family oriented.
It's a snob. Oh, snob conflicts with goofball.
Perfect. Perfect. A little similar to icy so I might change that.
Or wait, was it mercy?
Well, I think it changes for her because she's a teen. Okay. Yeah, it does.
Let me fix. Let's continue with Azera. Hello. Hello.
It was kind of a look for her.
Kind of want to change up her face a little bit.
No.
Oh, my God.
What is that? Why is her head so huge? Is she like?
I can't. You know what? I'm just gonna go back to what I had.
Because that was the closest.
Yeah, it gave her a straight five head.
That was not it. Why are these? Is her head?
Oh, actually that kind of helped. Because I don't know why her forehead was so like
huge. It can make her head big. No. It's not what I wanted. Oh, no. I think I messed it up.
Oh, wait. No, it's fine. I think. I think that looks fine. Color Azera's eyes.
There. I think they're orange. Yeah, they are.
So it could be light. Actually, can I make them? Damn, I can't do like yellowish or anything.
Strani gave us all orange eyes.
I still can't get rid of this freaking five head.
If I elongate her face, will that help? All right, let's do hair. This hair is pretty close.
Oh, this is literally her hair, though. Can I please make her forehead just smaller?
Why is her forehead so big?
Bro.
Please let me fix her forehead.
All right, let's. I have to change her eyebrows, too, to just little circles.
I don't think there's anything like that in this. I give her no eyebrows.
What is the difference between these no eyebrows and these no eyebrows? There's no difference.
No, I hate it.
I give her really thick eyebrows. No, I don't like it.
I kind of looks like it. Can I make them like.
She looks perpetually surprised. Her hair seems like a helmet. I know. I just hate it.
There's nothing better.
What is that? I don't understand. Why does her head look like that? How do I fix it?
That's actually cute.
That looks like my all-in.
Okay, all right, let's fix her eyebrows and make her eyes a little bit bigger.
No, no, no, this is not what I wanted.
All right, I guess that's fine. That's actually, she looks cute.
All right, I can't fix the forehead. That's just goes as it's going to get.
It has to be as if my aunt is married.
She could release an auntie.
Is there a, all right, is there a, let's, let's, uh, let's work on that body.
Give you a little bit more belly. Yeah, a little bit more thigh.
Just, wait. Oh my God.
When the thighs don't match the BBL.
Her look like muscular.
Whoa, Ben.
Yeah.
Chicken legs.
Okay, her every day.
These are two very different outfits. Why are they so close to each other?
Oh my God, literally cat woman, but it kind of works with the gloves.
I don't know why. It kind of just like,
kind of just like feels right.
Let's see. There's nothing like flowy.
Make that waist a little bit more snatched.
She's thick, but she's still snatched ladies and gentlemen.
Damn, I kind of like that.
Can I make it purple?
No, that looks so ugly. Never mind.
Let's give her a purple tracksuit.
It's Lulu, ladies and gentlemen. It's Lulu.
All these just make her look like an old woman and also my aunt.
Let me just, let me change the face shape a little bit.
No, no, no, no, no. No, what's up with this philtrum?
Oh my God.
I forgot to give Amy her like missing teeth. Hold on, let me do that.
Amy, show me your mouth. Open up your mouth, ma'am.
Where do I do your teeth? I forget.
Perfect. You get a, you get a cool gap. What is this? Oh, let's break braces.
No, we'll do a cap. That looks terrifying, but it's fine.
Just don't, don't, don't open your mouth ever.
Gonna upload the household systems workshop. Why do you guys want me to? For what reason?
How do I fix that? I don't like her mouth.
Okay, I kind of liked what I had before.
That looks cute. Okay. That looks, not the outfit. Fuck the outfit. The outfit looks like trash.
Is that a Zura? Yeah.
They're just gonna use it as a time for scientific purposes. Yeah, I'll do it. You guys can dress
up, dress us up and make better mods. Let's see, can I please get rid of this outfit on you?
Why does this actually fit her?
Grandma ma'azu. I hate the makeup though. Care to the makeup.
It kind of works. It's kind of a vibe. Yeah, I think it's, yeah, the markings like the body.
I think you're right. Oh wait, can I give her tattoos? That's right. I should be able to give her tattoos.
Where's the tattoos? Okay.
Ooh, sick.
No, no. Let's see.
This high key makes me want to give myself tattoos. What? Why does that kind of work? That's really pretty.
You can't even see that. Oh wait, can I get rid of, hold on, get rid of all the tattoos. I'll do like,
they don't have face tattoos, trash.
Is there a league tattoo? Probably. I think tribal would work for her.
I think that would kind of work. Ooh, that's actually cute. A little bit of henna moment.
I kind of like, I might go with that. I wish I could change the color to make it like a different
color or whatever. What? Oh, can you give her a sims tattoo or a little heart?
Can I do one on each arm? Oh, I can. Okay, that's kind of cool.
Ah, indeed. This kind of just looks like a goat. It looks kind of looks like a goofy deer,
but I know it's not. I know it's like wings or a heart or whatever. I want to do that.
Damn, she thick. Of course it's a zur. I got to make her thick.
Yeah, I think that fits the goddess theme. That's kind of sick too, to be honest. I like the chest
piece, subtle. I think that's like Romanian. I've seen like a Romanian tattoo artist have that sort
of style, I swear. That's me. Actually, no, I shaved my legs yesterday, but I only shaved
like the bottom half on my leg. I was so lazy. Oh, I needed to put like a nicotine patch on
Strani. That's right. I was going to use one of these and put it as a nicotine patch
for her every day. You can't tell it's there. She's wearing no shoes.
Can I do body please?
Milka wearables. I need something that looks like a nicotine patch.
Perfect.
Perfect. Let's put another one on her belly.
Actually, no, that doesn't work. I like it on her arm. Let's get rid of the port though.
I like it. Sick.
Can you move them? I don't think so. Puts them everywhere.
It's kind of works, guys. I don't know. Hold on. Let me...
Is there like... I'd prefer her in like pants though, rather than a skirt.
Or like some shorts.
Some panties. That actually kind of goes.
Because you know how she has like her little thing in the front?
Yeah, that's her every day, guys. Can I make the tattoos purple? I don't think so.
The snooze dip. Guys, stop asking what I'm gonna make those mods. It'll be like another time.
Oh my god.
I kind of like that. It's kind of a look. That's it, guys.
Yeah, I'm looking at her current outfit. Okay, and she's wearing like...
She wears like light socks. Well, she wears purple ones.
Yeah, she wears purple thigh highs. Can I make them?
Or maybe I can do...
That actually kind of works, but we want to... I want her to remain sultry.
Because I want her toes out, so I'm not gonna do that. Yeah, we'll just keep them like that.
Yeah, I don't know because like I like it because it works, but like if it wasn't the right color.
But they don't have the right color, which is annoying. These ones kind of work, but...
That does look stupid. Okay, let's get rid of those. Hello.
What do you think, bleeding heart? She's kind of mommy.
Damn, mama. Damn. Oh my god. Okay, four more. What is this?
I wanted this for Isara, for formal. It's kind of sick.
Put her in a cutesy tracksuit.
Actually, I like that more because that matches her hair.
As a bleeding heart would. And then for her...
Probably nothing.
I actually could see her in the bathrobe because that goes with her hair color. Let me get rid of her shoes.
I kind of like that. Can I get it better? I know there's a different towel.
Oh my god, that would actually work. She just sleeps because she's always walking around.
Wait, no, I'll do that for her bathing suit. Can I do that for her bathing suit? I don't know.
I'll try to do it for her bathing suit.
Okay, that one's a shorter one.
I kind of... Because you know, her outfit, her loading screen, her bedroom, you know?
Wait, I'm going to see if I can do that for her.
Okay, yep, that's her bathing suit. And this will be her sleepwear.
Why is this kind of a fit? Oh my god.
Bruh. It doesn't make sense that she's wearing it.
So I'm going to change that, but like, say, um, gheat.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, it's sneezing close to the thing.
I wanted to see this on her. No, I don't like any of these for the party.
Uh, let's do full body party.
No. That's actually cute. She looks very mythical.
Put her in that. Oh my god.
Wait, are there different colors for this?
This is cute. She looks so good.
I kind of like it though.
She looks so classy.
I think I might give her that.
The neutrals in her hair. I think I like the gray version the most.
I kind of like, she's like casual comfy because you know, Zara's comfy.
Azura rocks it. God damn. Look at her titties, bro. I'm kind of feeling it.
So it's either like that, but that looks really nice for a party though.
Maybe I'll do this.
I'll do that one for the cold weather. I'll do that for cold weather.
She wears that for cold weather. That's what I'll do. That makes sense.
What the heck is that outfit?
That looks, that looks so uncoated. Get these stupid things off her. Get them off.
Take, why is she wearing these? Get them off her face.
The necklace. I don't even know why the necklace is there.
I don't know how to get the necklace off.
How the heck is there a necklace on her and I can't take it off? Is that part of the outfit?
Azura's serving. She truly is. Oh, getting married to Azura. Sorry, this is cold weather
outfits. What am I doing? That's cute too.
Oh my God, I forgot about this though. That'll be her hot weather outfit.
Or maybe that will be her party outfit.
Guys, Azura can rock anything. I don't know what to do.
She's so, like, she just eats. Oh my God, the corset back.
That's humans.
Okay.
I don't like the necklace. How do I get rid of the necklace? What if I?
Cold weather outfit, folks.
Oh, actually, wait.
Hold on, folks. She kind of rocks this though. Virgin slayer outfit. Oh my God, bro.
Guys, I, yeah, I just hold on. Let me fix her freaking shoes. Oh my God, guys.
Guys.
Guys, not the Uggs. Not the Uggs. Get rid of those Uggs. No way.
That's the one. This is the one, boys. I think that's the one. Okay. I didn't do her hot weather
outfit though. No, we don't want the...
That looks, again, like one of my aunties in that freaking outfit.
That cat food's going off.
Who would dispenser my beloved?
Yeah, you've technically seen her in that sweater.
Don't worry, Fia. I'll feed you after I make myself.
Oh, actually, wait.
I kind of like this undress.
Rock angel. Why can't Azura just like eat anything? She just served. She left no crumbs, bro.
Full body hot weather outfit. Okay, hold on. Let's just...
I need to get rid of this.
Yes.
No.
What are they? These are...
She looks cute in that. Even she's the only one that could rock the hat.
Oh, queen? Azurian glasses?
Yep, got it.
This is for hours until it returns.
I like... Yeah, I like the shoes. Let me see if I can change the color of the dress.
I don't like any of the colors for the dress.
Okay, maybe it's the makeup that's throwing me off. I'm like, nothing looks good. It's the makeup.
It's the beach episode, cowgirl.
Let's get rid of this hat. Although it is... Look, she rocks a hat, though.
I feel like this could be better. Sunglasses, you said?
That's kind of... That kind of rocks. She looks kind of badass.
I just feel like there could be something better here.
I just feel like there could be something better.
Oh, precisely. Literally, this is so much better.
What? Sick. What else do we got?
Also sick.
Actually, I think I like the pants the most. The jumpsuit.
I think I like the jumpsuit the most.
Another color. Oh, what would she look like with the hat with this, actually?
Wait, how do I get a hat?
No, I think that looks the best. She looks so cool. She's just like, yeah,
I'm ready to step out in the town. Oh my god. Wait, though. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait. I feel like the hot dog the most. Guys, because you all know Azur from the south,
so you know she got to rock that hat. You know she's going to rock it.
Save a horse ride a cowboy, am I right? Yee-haw. Yee-yee. Yee-yee.
Yee-yee. Okay, so that, I actually think I like the cowboy hat. It's kind of a mood.
That's cute. She's so fucking cute. Oh my god. All right, I think that's Azur, guys. I think that's
Azur. I think that's Azur. I think we're moving on to me.
And there I am. There I am, everybody.
Azur. I don't know how it can get better than this.
They got that. I didn't even need to randomize or anything.
Hello, my name is Sheeby Cottonbomb. Can I get it? Yeah, like, damn.
Yep. Wait, what is this? Oh.
Oh.
What? I can change everybody's sexual orientation?
What? Can I make us okay?
Okay.
This sim feels jealous of any romantic parties.
Why are there romantic boundaries in the sims? I...
Well, I think they're all default checked off, yes, so that's fine.
Yeah, okay.
This is Azur.
Still look behind this crazy DLC. Okay, let me just try to find myself.
If it's a fwima.
Yeah.
No. What is that hair?
Why is this Taylor Swift?
With locks, bro. Why is this Taylor Swift with locks?
I can't.
No, what is happening?
Oh my god, you look like a predator.
Oh, Miba Shaila. You know what? No, I don't resonate with that face.
Oh.
No, I get closer and it gets bad.
Fia's being cute.
Again, this looks like Taylor Swift, except she's Gyaru.
I don't...
I'm a little bit thicker.
Okay, I'm... I can work with that. Let me change the chin. Let's change the skin tone.
Okay, all right.
Since Ronnie's hair be pink.
Yeah, but she's green woman, so her hair is green.
Okay, you know what? Hold on. Let me check what her hair would look like with pink.
Does that look right to you?
I don't think so. Actually, I think Emmy's hair color should be more like this.
Actually, or is that my hair color? And my hair color is more like this now.
But Emmy's hair in her model is just like very orange though.
His lips are huge because she's got DSL.
So, maybe make them smaller. She's got little pouty lips.
That actually looks better.
I can't... No, you can't do two tones.
Let me make my mouth a little bit smaller.
My eyes need to be a little closer together.
You can't... I can't put them closer together.
There we go. Hair. There's not going to be drills. I don't...
Yeah, my hair's pretty white and my eyes are red. Although, I could make them blue.
Oh, that's not my hair. My eyes...
God, give me gross.
Because I couldn't make my eyes blue now if I wanted to.
Or I can make them red. The red looks better. I look old by now, but it's fine.
This is face reveal. Yeah, guys, this is me. This is exactly what I look like in person.
Let me put... Give myself some makeup. Give myself some eyeliner like straw knees.
Here's a G. Cocho, you're a lie.
When blue, I had people look at you. Let's give a little bit of a...
You know, I don't really like glossy like that. I don't like the two-tone.
Where is the lip I gave straw knee?
I don't know where it went. I do like the diffused lip. The diffused lip is nice.
Here it is. I actually do usually like... If I wear a lipstick, I do do like the kind of like the
K Korean style. Let's do like a soft pink. Actually, I think red would probably be the
most accurate.
Do you?
Nope, nope, nope, nope. Let's keep the hue what it was. Let's let's put it back.
What is this? Capacity?
Yeah. Put a little blush.
Hold on. Let me put on my actual face.
Yeah, that's me guys. Yeah, that looks about right.
Wait, what's the... What is this?
Oh, there's contour? What the hell?
Bro, I'm contouring my face. Don't mind if I do.
I look like such a girly girl. What is up with that? Let me change my nose.
Boomi, hello, how can I help you sir? You can't lay on my keyboard. He's staring at my sim.
Can I... What the heck happened? I don't know what just happened.
Projecting my own face onto this. Although, no, it honestly looks nothing like me, but you know.
I need some boy. You smell like camp food. Oh, squeezed a pouch. Don't mind if I do.
He's staring at him. Okay, that looks pretty... Yeah. I feel like I need to be like more darker.
Like my eyebrows. Because my eyebrows are black and they're thin. Oh yeah, there you go.
That's pretty cute. All right.
I will be adding a beauty mark.
Yep.
What is this? No, I don't have that. What is this? Black lines? Damn.
Oh, little Marilyn Monroe moment.
What is this? Oh my god, these... I actually have freckles like this on my face.
That's really cute. I'll take those off though. Oh, I already clicked that. Give my head forehead
wrinkles. Okay, hold on. We got to go back to this, guys. Ew, hold on. Let me just fix the outfit just
real quick. Because I can't stay until... What the heck? That was not there before. Where'd it go?
Did you guys see that split second of something else? What the heck?
That looks so stupid.
Perfect. I look like what's her face from... I don't even know.
We'll keep that on for now while I do this.
Ew, I can't stand to look at it though. The makeup is bad.
My aspiration...
Friendships faster. Fortune.
Deviants. What do you guys think mine would be? Knowledge. Knowledge.
Fam... Nah, we know. Family's only with cat. Deviants?
You guys say deviants?
Popular... Let me see. What are the popularity ones? Oh, snap.
Be a positive influence. Become a famous comedian.
I do want to make a lot of friends. Maybe I want to make a lot of famous comedians.
Real estate. Well, I can't... That's like... Because I can't...
Let me see. What's under fortune? Fabulously wealthy.
Owning the biggest fanciest home. I already... Owning Wonderland, I guess.
Knowledge. Peter Wiz. Renaissance. Nerd brain. I think?
Joke star. Let's do that. Let's do joke star.
Yeah, I like that. Why do I look like Nicki Minaj?
Let's see. What are my likes? I like to cook comedy naturally. I like all of these things.
Oh, let's do gardening. Mischief.
A video gaming writing. Yeah. Wait, hold on. I need to do more. Favorite color? Red.
Oh my god. Oh my god, my voice is annoying. Hold on. Let me change my walk.
Swagger walk. Thank you.
The popcorn. I've only burnt popcorn. That was the first time I've ever burnt popcorn in my life, bro.
Ew.
Narskosmiva, huh? Holy nine, Mokosa. Holy nine, Mokosa. Holy nine, Krupova.
Uh, what's the...
No.
Wistedib-sarpava. A-wistedib-sarpava. Yeah, that's me.
A-banzan-a-satorb. I think my voice is a little bit higher.
And a prep kid-off.
Why is it a valley girl? Because I don't know. Sometimes I do a valley girl voice.
Holy nine, Mokosa.
Guys, I can't find my voice again.
I'm not that deep.
I'll make the... Yeah, I'm in the center. All right.
Music genre. Let's do alternative electronica, hip-hop. Pop. Spooky.
Yeah.
Hates children. Bro, naturally.
Yeah, Marchand Clazoi.
Yes, yes, I'll do that. The discovered.
Let's see.
All right, you guys can pick the... Actually, no, I'm a bookworm.
I should be a klepto.
I should be a slob.
Guys, I don't know what to do for the other ones. Should I be a snob?
Mean.
Do me? You want me to be mean?
I'm not evil. I'm an evil bro.
Clumsy geek and glutton. How am I to glutton?
Non-committal. No, I don't like that.
I snack every stream. That doesn't make me a glutton.
You dicks. I just like to eat with you because you remind me when to eat.
Clumsy. That's accurate.
Who is calling me? I don't recognize that.
Uh, clumsy.
Hates children.
All right, you guys can pick the last one.
Food hacks. You're like, yeah, I eat every day.
I usually forget to eat. That doesn't make me a glutton.
All right, you guys can pick the last one for me. So I'll go through them.
Perfectionist. Perfectionist.
Back to back. Perfectionist. Genius. Incorrect.
I think I will put perfectionist. I'm a clumsy, but I'm a perfectionist.
Good fall.
No, actually, this is laugh at failure instead of becoming upset. That's incorrect.
I'll do goofball instead.
Kang. No, Kang.
It may needs the perfectionist tag. Maybe. I'll see. I think I should be able to pick it
when she ages up. It sounds so bad. Can I fix my face?
Can I please take off that makeup? It looks terrible.
That's not the makeup I had on before.
Oh, wait, put the bag.
Oh, that's you.
Can I take your glasses off, please? Okay, let's let's do hair.
Actually,
I said nobody looked at me like that.
What is the difference between these two that's bumped out really?
You're going to waste a slot like that. This is the, oh, actually, that may work,
but I don't like how it looked. Oh, no, never mind. Why is it a freaking bob in the back?
B.O.B., so they call a new bob?
I actually don't like how this looks. Why does my nose look like that?
Okay, myself a white woman nose.
My dad said I had a white woman nose the other day, and I'm like, that's not true,
because I have a little button nose, but it's not pointy like my mother's.
So I'm like, what are you talking about? I'm like, dad, that's not nice.
Can't believe you just say that to me.
What did you say?
Nose reveal when? Never.
It does look nice from far away, and it's not like we're going to be up and close to the
Sims all the time. So actually, I think I'll do that. I think I'll do that hair.
What? Is there eye shadow on?
Is there eye shadow on? No? Okay, because I'm like, what the hell?
I wish I could give myself bunny ears. That would be great.
All right, let's get into it, guys. Every day outfit. Let's find out.
Teachers bit. So it would be like a suit outfit.
Is there like a suit? That's cute. Actually, let me fix my body type real quick.
Let me throw in a bathing suit and do that.
Oh, that's fine. Huge. Not as big as Azura's though, but big. Snatch. Thighs are fine.
All right, that's good. Okay, sets.
Why do I look like I'm going to like... That looks so weird.
That actually looks kind of cute. Let me find jumpsuits. Yeah.
Oh, nobody look. Nobody look at me.
Can I find like a top jacket? I just need like a suit jacket. Can I please have a
button up? No, that's not it. Suit jacket.
This definitely like makes me look like a mom.
This definitely makes me look like a mom.
Can wear a jacket over a bra. That's a great question.
Okay, I feel like my poops need to be bigger.
This is this is definitely mommy. Let me get myself a skirt.
I can't tell if I like this one or that. Actually, I like the shorter one.
Yeah. Oh, hello. Can I just wear this?
Can I just wear that? Why are the shoulders so pointy?
Can I just wear that? Hold on. Actually, hold on. Hold on.
Hold on. Hold on. Work with me. Work with me. Work with me. Work with me.
Work with me, you guys. Hold on.
Just just hold on. Bear with me. I'm I'm I'm thinking.
It's it's coming to me.
I am cooking. Let me cook. Just just let me cook.
Let it let the cooking happen.
Let the cooking happen.
What is the difference between these two? Nothing. Oh, this is one have a line and one doesn't.
That actually kind of works.
Let's do my fingernails. No, I don't like the multiple colors.
Can I have like normally colored fingernails? Why are these both the same thing? Oh, one's matte,
one's not. Can I just have all red fingernails? What the hell is that?
That looks kind of weird, but I want longer fingernails. Why is this kind of cute though?
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. I'm kind of feeling this. Oh, is this the right one? Here it is. There we go.
Perfect. Yeah, get those red.
Is there like a short skirt I can wear?
Why? I could have sworn there was more short skirts. What happened to them all?
That's weird. I could have.
Where did the skirts go? There was more skirts than this.
Oh, I didn't even press that. That looks stupid. Not the clashing patterns.
I think that's going to be it. Let me see if I can...
Can I? What if I'm like...
Wait a second.
Wait. I kind of like the red. The red one does kind of eat them. Oh wait. Sorry, I'm snapping.
I think I like the red.
Okay, let's go with that. I'm just wearing panties and that's it. This is my outfit.
That's what I wear. Okay. Formal. What is this? That's ugly.
I just wear it like... I just add pants.
Ooh, the makeup's nice.
That's a little bit much.
Why does this kind of fucking look sick on me though? It is a Jessica Rabbit dress. That's true.
It is Jessica Rabbit-y.
Where'd it go? All I have is the dude ones.
Okay, let me look. Let's look at some more full-body dresses.
Because there's that, but there's also this. Oh. Holy moly.
I'm not bad. I'm just drawn that way. It sounded like Meg Gara.
Yeah, that one needs booba support, bro. I kind of want to get...
Give me a flat tummy. Kind of. Kind of eats, guys. I think that's it.
Full-body athletic.
A few stylized looks. Trying to think of... I usually just wear something like this,
to honest, when I go to the gym. Kind of works. Is there like a red version?
Where's the shirt?
Where's the shirt? Is it selected? I can't tell.
I wish if I clicked on the shirt, it would just show the shirt at the freaking top.
I don't like that.
Is there like a red? No, it's only pink. Give me red.
But it doesn't look good. What about this red?
Damn, curvy as fuck.
F the leggings.
Where those fishnets go? I just throw fishnets on me. I don't care about that.
I'm getting a... yeah. Working on Madem. They're better shorts.
Is everything pink?
There's like different shades of red and it looks stupid. I have like cartoon
character proportions. Don't worry about that. Give myself an America.
I kind of like the America shirt. Oh wait.
That kind of works. Can I give myself black shorts instead then?
It's like a reverse of my normal outfit. Black. Or black?
Can I just like...
I just exercise in panties. Skin tight.
Those are just skinny jeans. What?
This is how I exercise, boys. So let's throw some leggings on.
What is that? I'm sort of sick. All right, let's put on some nice sneakers. Perfect.
I'm looking for the right shade of red and I can't find it.
That's going to bother me.
I don't even think I'm going to play the game today because I stream at three hours
doing the Gunpla for members. I like how it's taken me so long to do this.
I have to take a break also because I'm getting a headache. So I don't want to have a...
I don't want to have to cancel the members stream. All right, that's cute.
Kind of a look but not what we're going for.
There we go.
Oh, we love it. Hold on.
This is what I sleep in on the daily. Hold on, I might do the reverse of this outfit.
This is so it goes with the black butter. Yeah, looks cool.
It looks kind of nice and then look and then naturally
got to do the bunny slippers. Does that make them black bunnies? I like the white. It's just like
random. Bye bye. I love the other dress in a press collab. I want to play the game so bad.
Um, cool.
It's kind of a look. Nice party. Why is this such a freaking cute outfit?
Hello? It's not what I want though. We're going to do a stylized look.
Or just a bunch of dude outfits. I should probably wear the cougar outfit.
No, I just want to do that one character from Hoony Pop.
Oh, that actually is cute.
It's kind of cute. It's kind of a look. Jessica.
I kind of like this better.
No, that kind of looks too mommy because like I'm a hot mom, you know.
Perfect. I think that's great. Can I get that in red though?
Close enough. Love to see it.
Can I wear lingerie to a party?
Hey, what type of party are we having?
This is very cute on me too. Looks good on me and Azura.
Uh-huh. No, I would not wear that to a party.
You will not catch dead. I'm mad I'm wearing that to a party.
Let me look at dresses. Trying to find all the dresses.
It's really cool that I have a gunbook.
Um, a little basic. That's a little cute. Can I see a red version?
Not feeling it too much. I don't like the stripes.
Oh, is this in red? Damn, if that was in red, that would have been perfect. It's not in red.
All right, we'll go with the OG.
Yeah, me and Marcy can wear the same dress in different colors.
Oh, snap. Uh, let me change the color of this top and I'll actually do that.
Let's do black. That's not black. That's like brown. What?
I have like, let's just do red.
Let's go to the beach, beach. Ninky Minjaj.
We'll keep it a classic, you know?
I know the room is, it does make it just go boy.
Yeah, it looks nice. It's kind of, kind of it.
Like my little drill hair.
I should just like have heels at all times. I wear heels even to the, the clown shoes.
Um, even to the beach, I'm just in high heels.
Wait, that actually kind of works. Oh yeah, other open-toed shoes stuff.
Wait, what are these freaking dolly heels? Those are so cute. What the hell?
I realized my skin tone looks a little washed out. I might change my skin tone.
Um, let's get these in red. That's kind of cute.
What is that?
Oh, what if I wear the sundress?
I look nefarious. Uh, rock angel.
He leads to the beach, heels to bed.
Wait, did I? No, I had the bunny slippers.
There's the micro in the bikini.
Hold on, I'm just gonna put this on for now.
And then I'm gonna fix my freaking makeup.
Um, let me fix the outfit.
Hey! Oh, that's cool. I can't stop teasing.
Like, this is such a 2000s outfit. Like, what is it doing here?
What? Am I going to Italy? Oh my god, those, those stripes are doing me favors. I'll tell you that.
Thank you. I can't stop teasing. That like hurt.
I swear to hell. It's hot outside. I'm wearing a bunny outfit. I should just have this view every day.
Hell yeah!
Wine shirt in the fanny pack. Let's go. I actually have this dress and I'm not even joking. I have this dress
except it's a lighter.
That's kind of crazy to me. I literally have that dress. Um, a clip that's shorter.
What up? You have the red Hawaiian shirt? I think I like that. What about this? No.
Maybe I can wear like, ooh. Bottoms? Any bottoms in the chat?
Can I just see all skirts? I feel like there are more skirts than this.
And they're just hiding from me.
All right.
I've actually worn something like this, but then, um, yeah, I've worn like fishnets with it.
This is literally an outfit that I've worn before.
Nice slings. Two, two, two. Make some man go. I can't whistle.
That's the way they all come through. Like, low cut. See through. Sure does that make you.
And I just set them up. Anywhere's my nails?
Let's go to the beach. Beach and Ninky Minjaj. I don't know if it's so.
That looks right. Y'all.
Oh, hello.
Yeah, it looks like I'm going to a warp store.
There's our boxer briefs. What are those? Aren't those like briefs?
I don't know what those are, but I see the little thingy,
little little little pee pee holder, maybe a white top. Honestly, wait.
Yo, I kind of like that.
Casual madam. Wait, casual madam.
I look so goofy, though. I like that. I like the more youthful look of the other one.
A moment with those boxers or brief. You know what? I'm literally going to just wear
men's underwear just because it looks right with this outfit. It just goes. It's kind of a mood.
I hate like these are so like this is so ugly.
Wait, I'm Guy Fieri.
Wait, that just looks like this looks like a character from a show.
What is it? Look like I can't I can't tell who it looks like.
After hours.
Cute.
I write sins, not tragedies.
I chime in with the half of you people I've ever heard of.
Closing the goddamn sword. No, it's much better to waste these kinds of things with the sets up.
Wait a second.
You spin me right around, baby, right around. Wait, hold on.
What did I have for formal? What did I have for party? Fuck it. No, we're not.
We're doing that outfit. We're matching Emmy.
And strongy.
Where is it? Oh, there it is.
I just want to know your name.
Yeah, is there any fur? That's a great question. Oh, frick. Go away. Go away.
No, I want. Okay. Let's see. Let's see. Let's see.
Tops. Jackets. No fur. Jackets with no fur. No, it's fur.
The whole, wait, actually, I might just do that outfit that I almost gave a zero,
except I put her in the sweater dress.
Where is it?
Actually, I should have actually keep it on feminine. Actually, no.
Yeah. So some other stuff keeps popping up in the morning.
Yo, can I take off the choker?
Okay, let me just switch to that and then switch to that. Oh, nope. I won't let me take off the choker.
Can I take the color of this?
I've worn this outfit before, minus probably black leggings. Let me see. Where the heck did I go?
Wait. Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait.
This is going to be my formal wear.
No, we don't want formal. Where is it?
I'm sorry, Jessica. You're gone. It's a mood, but it's not at the same time. Where is it?
Okay, red formal party.
We'll be, where'd it go?
Party? Yeah, party and party and yeah. Fun, fun, fun, fun, looking forward to the weekend.
Yeah, that's about right. That's about right.
Why do I look kind of cute with the choker on? I might keep that on. Is there a red one?
Oh, yeah, that works. Let me just take off this bracelet.
So the choker actually works.
Why is I could do every accessory besides freaking every day? Let me put my toes on.
I can't see my toes, but it's fine. Okay, let me see if I can change my skin tone a little bit.
Nope.
Okay.
I don't like these.
This is just sheebie. Sorry, no, this is just sheebie.
This is, this is, this is sheebie. I love vanilla.
If I stay cool toned, I'm just turning purple.
All right, we'll just stay with what we had.
There's a skiter for the slings do. It literally just slides through stuff. Like it's just like,
it doesn't really make a difference.
It doesn't say to slide the customized color, but then it like lightens it just the slightest bit.
It's rich. All right. I think we got the outfits. So that's that's it for that.
Let me get that. We got that. We got that.
Then you got that for a party. Then we got that where we're going swimming.
You got that when it's hot outside. It looks kind of goofy, but you know, it's a look.
And that for when it's, you know, cold weather like fall, you know.
Wait, can I wear baby doll heels with this?
No, I don't care if it's hot, whether or not give me the baby doll heels.
I'm just going to look like, you know, a whore all the time.
This looks so stupid.
Let me see if I can find a full body outfit that's like better.
Or at least like shorts.
And it's hot weather. Can I just wear...
Yeah.
Wait, no.
Take a white...
You like what you see? I look like Angelic.
Ooh, indeed, sister. They don't come in white, they only come in gray.
You know, madam would be stepping on the town like this.
You know, I just go outside, just walk, just walk over and be like, hey guys, what's going on?
It's hot out.
Is it ever like a red top?
Look stupid. I like really like the shirt.
Oh my god. Oh my god.
This is just like, it looks like a one piece. I'm looking very on to you right now on this outfit.
Wait, where's my stomach?
Oh wait, no, it's because my underwear is there.
Why do I like the America look, guys?
Gonna make my sisters? Not right now.
Why do I like that?
What if I make the heels? Because I'm, you know, one of the Americans, you know.
Hey guys.
You say one of the Olympics.
Did they? I don't want you looking.
Merica. Look, yeah. No, no, no, no, no, no. We're not doing that.
Can I get like a flowy skirt?
Yo, actually, wait, hold on, let me cook.
Never mind. Never mind.
Never mind. The cooking did not go well. It kind of got burnt. It kind of just didn't work out.
Let's see that.
And where is that one vest?
I'm right. I chime in with the haven't you people ever heard of closing the goddamn door? No. I don't
know why it's British. Why are there so many evil coded stuff? Am I just a scene boy?
What? Let's just walk around like that. There we go. Hot weather outfit.
There's a black one. Actually like it in white. It's kind of a mood.
I wouldn't ever wear this, but what the fuck is a kilometer?
Okay, but I should probably finish. It's taken me four hours to make all of us guys.
It's like, what? No, I hate this outfit, though. I actually hate this.
Guys, I can't, I can't, I can't figure out what I like.
This is funny that I have an outfit.
Let's get rid of that.
Oh, we should just keep it basic. I feel like I should just be keeping it basic.
How to basic, if you would. If you will, if you would.
That looks pretty good, to be honest with you. Like, I don't know about you guys, but that looks
pretty damn good for a hot weather outfit, don't you think? Pretty damn good. Yeah, it's clown.
Those are just PJs.
I wish they had shorter dresses. That looks great, actually. Or alternatively.
Why is my hair clipping through the hot dog? Or alternatively.
Or, that actually looks pretty nice. However, however, why does it look good? But,
it looks too warm. Oh, wait, this? Let me change the top, and maybe if I do like a crop top?
Wait, is that a full body thing? I can't just have that. I just want the skirt on that.
I just want the skirt. I don't care about anything else. That's stupid. What?
Crop top. Drop top.
I remember when infinity scarves were a thing. That was an interesting time.
Just make myself naked. I'll move all my clothes in Minecraft, of course. What?
Wait.
Can I just wear this when it's hot?
I'm looking for the right shade of red.
Yeah, perfect. Yeah, it looks right.
I could wear whatever I want when it's hot. You promise?
You promise? Do you promise?
Why is nothing red?
Why are these two different shades when they're supposed to be part of the same set?
Okay, wait. I found it.
Lovely. Can I get some like...
That looks good for hot weather, don't you think?
That looks pretty good for hot weather, guys.
I know. I could have sworn that the old games had color wheels and you could just like pluck them.
Like, I'm so sure that that was a thing.
At least try to make them look like shorts.
Nope, they don't look like shorts.
This is ridiculous!
Oh, that's hot. I just walk her. I just take off my jacket.
I just take off my jacket. That's it.
It looks like I should have a belly ring.
What are these? What are those?
I'm ready to go.
Let's do a little open toe. No, they have to be red.
I don't really like the open toes. Kind of look gross, except for those ones. Those are nice.
Again, it's not the same red, so it's bothering me because that's just how my mind works.
For hot weather, it's probably good to have the toes out.
I also think you just need to pick one.
Listen, I'm trying my best out here.
Aren't you entertained?
Isn't this entertaining for you?
I should probably wear a shirt.
No, I don't like it though. I like just having my bra out because it looks funny, but will be appropriate.
Honey, we need some dinners.
Yeah, I do. Yeah, yeah. Okay. All right, guys. This is the final looks for everybody.
Hold on.
So you got Mercy. Mercy, Modest.
Mercy, Modest. Gameplay time. No, I know I was going to take hours to do just to design us.
That's why this isn't playing the Sims and making my gen mates. No, it's just designing my gen mates, guys.
All right, let me get... I see...
Let me go. Wait, hold on. Shrani's hair should be...
Not pink. She doesn't look like herself. It should be green. It looks better green.
Then we got Shrani.
Then we got Emi.
Wait, is that her everyday? No, that's not her everyday outfit.
Hello?
Then we got Emi.
Long Emi. Long Emi and I see. Then we got Ezra.
Actually, it looks probably the best set of all of us. Hold on. Let me grab her other outfit.
Her OG outfit.
Then you got Ezra.
Oh my gosh, she doesn't wear pants.
And then you got me.
It looks so silly.
I can't get over it. How silly it looks.
Oh my god.
I wish I could make Emi cuter.
Feel her.
I think I should get a design. What do you mean? Make her a child?
What?
Let me see what it looks like.
No, no, no. That's bad. That's terrible.
Yeah, that looks better. What do I see?
Why is her hair black?
That doesn't make any sense.
Why is she a little boy child? Why is her hair black?
I see a look like that.
What happened to her?
Why is her hair black?
That's so weird.
Wait. No, did it mess up everything? Hold on.
She looks good black hair.
Yeah, I just like fully reset for some reason.
Why does this baby look like that? I hate it so much.
That was crazy.
Okay, that's better. Did it mess up Emi's stuff too then?
Oh, it did. Damn it.
No, no, no, no, no, no. She looks like Chucky. No.
I actually, I don't think I like the cap teeth. Let me take out these. Why does she have like plugs?
It's like she doesn't have freaking gauges.
Give me, I think I might give her braces instead. I think that's cute.
Let's do braces instead.
Yeah, Emi with braces.
I've only seen like one VTuber with braces.
All right. All right. I think that's it, folks.
I'm her, her, her, her, her. She, she, she take a look. It's me, me, me.
Chucky, you're Coraline.
Coraline. All right.
Modis. Look at that. Hold on.
Take a picture.
Wait.
Oh, it's Johnny. We're all the same height. I wish you could, I could change the heights.
Can I upload a picture? Share a household to the gallery?
Oh, is this like where I like set, like say who, like that I made it?
LOL. It's the veeler girls.
Do I just do it? How do I share it?
Can they do it? I don't know what I'm doing.
Does that make it so you guys can download the model? Because that would be fine.
What? Oh snap. Okay. We have $30,000. It's fine. I know the mother load. Willow Creek.
I feel like.
What? This world does not have any good starter lots. Oh, why would you give that to me then?
Let's do Willow Creek. Select a place to live.
A hovel.
I cannot afford it.
Wait, how do I do the mother load?
He did. Oh my God. Can I have them?
Say, I'm girl. You live like this. Zero DLC. Listen, I'm not spending money on that right now.
How?
Tilled.
Frick, I don't think I can do it. Hold on.
How to do mother, wait, how should you cheat Sims for?
Okay.
Help. No.
How do I do the mother load cheat?
Mother load cheat. Sims for.
Mother load. Why is it in caps? Mother load. Why isn't it working?
Why can't I get more funds right off the rip? I used to be able to do that.
I have to get a house first. That's stupid. I wanted to get one of these. I want to get a mansion.
Well, I'm moving us. Where's the cheapest one?
We're living here.
Can this be a perfect home? It's a patch of grass.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. We're going to do that. I'm going to buy the mansion.
Mm-hmm. Oh my god. Look at us. That's so crazy.
Why is the camera flying away? Why did it go all over here? What the heck?
Dag dag. Dag dag.
What's happening?
Hold on. I'm not traveling. Go back.
Hold on.
Don't worry about it. I'm doing it so fast I can't keep up.
I just want a million dollars. I spelled it wrong.
Copy and paste? No, I'm getting my stuff up. My words for a minute.
Uh-huh.
Yay. Wow. How did we do that? That's crazy. How do I move out?
How do I? They're all just like chatting. How do I sell?
Okay, that's great. Thank you.
I got charisma. Don't know how.
Is there a comedy?
Phone? Where's the phone?
Is it loading?
That's great.
Oh, okay. I was just taking a while.
Okay. Oh, let's see.
Four beds, three bathrooms. Four beds, three bathrooms.
Three. No, that's not enough.
What's this?
Oh, it's the goth house.
We can live right next to the goths. I don't know.
This one's more expensive though. We'll buy the more expensive one.
How do I get it?
I want it.
What's this?
Did I select it? Oh, it's already selected.
Why is that house selected?
Oh, they're not selected. I don't freaking...
We're going!
Furnished?
Bulldozed a lot because I suck at making some houses.
Wow!
I know there's a piano.
Yeah, I can probably like add another floor.
I can put in a pool. Oh yeah, pool right here. Perfect.
We got a gazebo. We can bury a body under. Perfect.
We got a little thing. Go fishing. Perfect.
How do I...
How do I go to the next floor?
How do I go to the next floor? Where am I?
I'm just watching TV. What am I watching?
If I tell gross joke, what if I select a zero?
We'll like... Oh, okay.
We can all sleep with each other. There's plenty of bedrooms.
Yeah, we can share. We can share beds.
Look at this. This is Emmy's room. She's already claimed it.
We can share. This is the Wheeler house, guys.
One more bed. No, because we can share a bed.
Why is Azera playing the violin badly?
And then Strani is playing chess with herself. That's insane.
Awesome. That's great. That's really cool. What am I doing outside?
Where is she?
Me and I see it. Where is she? You're just going to watch TV.
What are we watching?
Order pizza. Let's order a pizza for them.
What would that be under?
Business? Find a job? Save it?
How the frick do I order pizza? Home icon delivery. Oh, okay.
Zoomers?
Why is normal pizza delivery different? Oh, I'm ordering pizza.
Canadian bacon pizza? Let's get... I feel like all the girls will like pepperoni.
I'm talking about pizza. Mercy's talking about me.
My pizza's on the way. Perfect. Take a photo with the phone.
Why do I look so cute? I'm flirting. Am I flirting with Amy? I mean, I see.
No, I'm flirting with Mercy.
Why am I flirting with Mercy?
Oh, my God.
Get a pizza. Oh, that's a good idea. I might order pizza.
Do you guys want to order pizza? Do you guys want to order pizza together?
Like that pizza I had the other day was good. I'm like, I want pizza again.
Oh, here's the pizza. She may go get it. She may go get the pizza.
How do I rotate the camera? Is it control? Shift?
Is somebody going to enter the door?
Mercy's going to grab it. Thank you, Mercy.
Mercy, pick up the speed, sweetheart. Mercy.
Mercy, imagine you go to drop off a pizza and the person walks up to you like that.
What's Amy doing? Is she still gaming?
Amy's just gaming.
Was she playing fucking FIFA? What is this?
She's feeling inspired.
Okay, what's, what's, what's Strony doing?
Strony? Strony? Strony? Where are you?
Okay, what was that?
Camera options? Oh, I can take screenshots.
Oh, Mercy has identified a guppy. Thank you, Mercy.
Why is the Sarah playing the violin? I can't. How do I rotate the camera?
She's playing just with the voices.
She's fine. Is she going to go use the bathroom? Oh, wait. No, let me watch.
Oh, you're thinking about me? Is she walking like that? I forgot I made her walk goofy.
Strony? You coming to see me? Oh, look at us. We're having a good time. Oh my god.
Look at us. All we need is freaking, I need, I need a Zura. Like, I need us all down here
and in me too. Why am I flirting with everybody?
Oh, Mercy, what did I say?
Oh, did you see Mercy just get closer to me? Are you guys going to eat the pizza?
Call the mill. Strony, why don't you let everybody know the food's here?
Why are we doing musical chairs?
Oh my god, this is great, guys. This might be my new obsession.
I might Tamagotchi and all Sim stuff. Oh my god.
Look at us. Oh my god, this actually brings me so much joy. I'm not even kidding.
Look at, get the freaking thing out the way. How do I take a screenshot?
A break lent him. So chimzababi.
Yeah. Can I tweet this? Oh, the Tamagotchi's yelling at me. Hi, hi, what's up,
Tamagotchi? You pooped everywhere. Well, I'm not doing that right now. How do I,
how do I, what happens with this screenshot? Your pictures can be viewed. Camera options.
I want to upload this. Somebody, wait, you know what I'm going to do? I'm going to take an actual
screenshot. I took an actual screenshot. File, save.
All right, all right, all right, all right. Hold on.
Yay.
We're a happy family having pizza. Look at that. Oh my god, I'm like, I'm so happy right now.
This makes me so happy.
Wait, what? Why can't I, what's up with Ibi's skirt?
Yo, Ibi. We're just playing musical chairs. Oh, we're all sitting together.
Thank you. Thank you, Strani, for picking up after us.
So, I'm going to end stream here and take a little break.
I'm on a raid into, I think, I think, I think Strani's playing Bioshock, so I'll raid into her
and I'll be back for the member stream.
I hope you guys enjoyed. She can write jokes on a computer. Oh, I see a programmer? Dang,
okay, girls are incredible. But bye, guys. So, I stream at 7 p.m. Eastern. We're going to try to
build a gun plot. I've never built a gun plot before. I'm probably not going to be good at it,
and if I'm not good at it, I'm probably just going to Zatsu. Bye. Bye. Have a good time. I hope,
I'm glad you guys enjoyed. Why just use a toilet? Okay, Strani, you need to take a shower or bath.
I have to figure out how to play this game because I haven't played The Sims in a while,
and I don't think I ever put The Sims 4. Bye, everybody. See you later at the pizza party. I
just smacked the microphone. I'll see you at the pizza party. I'm getting just cheese pizza
because I'm regular. Oh my God, Strani's cooking. I don't know if Strani can cook. I don't believe
she could. All right, bye. Tell her, tell her, um, wait, no, it does because, because the RuneScape
streams. I don't know. I can't think of, don't forget the surprise. Yes, I'm going to post that right
after this. Thank you for the reminder. Oh my God, that's so good. Can you see my, oh,
excuse me? I can see my, thinking about steak. Why do I look crazy?
Look at us. Wait, where the fuck is IC? Is IC pissing somewhere?
Probably. Okay. Bye, guys. Bye. Bye. Bye. Just say Sim, just say Simlish Raid or something.
Smells bad. You should take a shower or a bath. Open your needs panel. How about that?